Programming Throwdown, Episode 188 World Models. Take it away, Jason. Hey, everybody. Excited to dive into world models. But as you know, we follow the sort of show protocol here. We're going to jump into our intro topic. I've been doing a lot of running. So just a bit of a background, I have a buddy Dave, and Dave came into town.
Programming Throwdown，第188期：世界模型。Jason，开始吧。大家好。很高兴能深入探讨世界模型。但如你们所知，我们这里遵循节目的惯例。我们要先进入开场话题。我最近一直在跑步。简单介绍一下背景，我有个朋友叫Dave，他来城里了。
and he asked if we wanted to go for a run. This is like September. And he was talking about how, you know, he's in really bad shape and he got into running and it kind of fixed a lot of issues he was having. And the last time I ran was probably like 10, 20 years ago. And so I just assumed that, oh, you know, I must be around the same level of performance.
他问我们要不要去跑步。那是九月份的事。他当时说他现在的身体状况真的很差，于是开始跑步，这解决了他很多问题。我上一次跑步大概是10到20年前了。所以我当时想，哦，你知道的，我的体能水平应该差不多吧。
No. Like I ran three blocks. I was like, about to pass out. And so that got me on the same level of performance. running kick. And the thing that's awesome now is, is there's so much technology. You know, like I have the Galaxy watch from Samsung and, you know, they have this running coach. So I'm up to like level six on the coach where, you know, I'm basically running 10Ks, you know, a couple times a week. And I've been just running almost every day since October. And it's, it's been awesome.
不。我跑了三个街区，感觉快要晕倒了。这让我开始关注跑步。现在最棒的是，科技太发达了。比如我有三星的Galaxy手表，他们有跑步教练功能。我现在已经练到教练的第六级了，基本上每周跑几次10公里。从十月份开始，我几乎每天都在跑。这感觉太棒了。
And the technologies, I think, has helped a ton. Like, you can measure your heart rate. It tells you if you're bouncing too much or if you're, you know, running with a good posture and all of that. Or at least I think they measure, they call stiffness is what they call it. But yeah, I've been a big fan. I know, Patrick, you've been running for a long time. Yeah, so I guess similar story. I guess we're just talking about being old programmers, I think.
我认为这些技术帮了大忙。比如，你可以测量心率。它会告诉你步幅是否过大，或者你的姿势是否正确等等。或者至少我认为他们测量的是所谓的“刚度”。总之，我是它的忠实粉丝。我知道，Patrick，你跑步很久了。是的，我想情况差不多。我想我们只是在谈论作为老程序员的感受。
Basically, like, yeah, my kids and maybe my nephews were over and, like, trying to play like soccer and just like running after the ball and then like stitch in my side. I'm like, wait a minute. This is like this is sad. And so yeah, I think about three years ago now. I think I picked up and started running. And so I've run more. I've run a little less, but I've stuck with it. I think, you know, I don't have this. My watch doesn't have the same measures as you. But yeah, similar. I have a, you know, you can get a pretty cheap, cheap watch, you know, just has GPS and, you know, some sort of hard. rate, whatever, and mostly be good to go, in my opinion, you know, if you're not going to,
基本上，我的孩子们，也许还有我的侄子们过来玩足球，我跟着球跑了几步，侧腹就开始疼。我在想，等等，这太可悲了。所以，大概是三年前吧，我开始跑步。我跑得多的时候多，少的时候少，但我坚持下来了。我想，我的手表没有你那些测量功能。但确实差不多。你可以买到很便宜的手表，有GPS和心率监测之类的，在我看来这就足够了，如果你不打算……
you don't have to take it serious. But there's like anything, there's people take it way too serious. And then there's, you know, you know, just you're out there doing it, having a good time, kind of what I try to do, a little bit in the middle. Like, I try to beat my own, you know, thing. But there's, whatever, like epigenetic stuff. So like if you, this is my theory. It makes me feel better. Like, if you ran track, you hear these people like, oh, after 20 years, I started running again, you know, for the first time. seriously and I ran and they'll say some obscene time. Oh, I ran, you know, only a 19 minute 5K. It was so sad. And you're like, my God, what? Like, I've been running for three years and I get run a sub 25k. Like,
你不必太认真。但就像任何事情一样，有些人太当真了。还有些人只是去跑跑，玩得开心，这正是我尝试做的，处于中间地带。我试着超越自己的记录。但不管怎样，还有所谓的表观遗传学之类的东西。这是我的理论，这让我感觉好受些。如果你以前练过田径，你会听到有人说：“哦，20年后，我第一次认真跑步，结果跑出了一个惊人的成绩。”比如，“哦，我5公里只跑了19分钟，太糟糕了。”你会想，天哪，什么？我跑了三年，5公里才勉强跑进25分钟。
screw you. But then it's like, oh, it turns out they ran cross country or, you know, like a high level soccer player in high school, you know. And so I think your body, you know, kind of remembers, like is epigenic, whatever we want. Like, your body learns to express certain things when you do something for a really long time. And when you're young, you're like, almost invincible. Like, There's like so much you can do. You can kind of just do anything and get better. But, you know, as a not young person, those things aren't true. But then a lot of the advice you read is from people who have been doing it a while.
去你的。但后来发现，他们高中时是越野跑选手，或者是高水平足球运动员。所以我认为你的身体是有记忆的，不管是表观遗传还是什么。当你长期做某件事时，你的身体学会了表达某些东西。当你年轻时，你几乎是无敌的。你可以做任何事并不断进步。但是，作为一个不再年轻的人，这些就不适用了。但你读到的很多建议都是来自那些已经跑了很久的人。
Makes sense. They feel like they have something to say. But they forget what it's like in the beginning, like all the aches and pains and the randomness. And they'll say, as an example, oh, you should go out for a run and never go above. And then they'll say some heart rate. It's like, listen, when you're first starting, you forget, like, walk five steps. And your heart's going to be above that. Like, just start moving.
这说得通。他们觉得他们有话要说。但他们忘记了刚开始时的感觉，比如所有的酸痛和不适。他们会举例说：“哦，你应该去跑步，心率永远不要超过……”然后说出一个心率值。听着，当你刚开始时，你忘了，走五步你的心率就会超过那个值。先动起来再说。
And then like, let that stuff come eventually. like set some goal that motivates you, that's fine. But you got to kind of tone down a lot of the, even the quote unquote beginner advice because it's like beginner again or, you know, beginner from someone who forgot what it was after. And even now, like, I find it hard to remember just like how much it hurt to finish,
然后让那些数据慢慢跟上。设定一个激励你的目标是可以的。但你必须降低那些所谓的“初学者建议”的门槛，因为那是“再次成为初学者”或者“忘记了初学者是什么样的人”给出的建议。即使是现在，我也很难回想起当初跑完一小段距离有多痛苦。
you know, some small distance, you know, now that I run more. And then there's always people though a lot faster, run a lot further, you know, I don't know. It's like anything in light, if you got to just find your contentment, I guess, but certainly from a fitness thing, so much better.
既然我现在跑得更多了。当然总有人跑得更快、更远，我不知道。就像生活中的任何事，你只需要找到自己的满足感。但从健身的角度来看，这真的好多了。
Like going up a flight of stairs, no problem, playing sports. Like all those little things, I forgot how much until I think about it. Like, remember when I would like avoid doing this because it would make me hot and sweaty
比如爬楼梯没问题，参加体育运动。所有这些小事，我忘记了它们有多重要，直到我开始思考。记得以前我会避免做这些事，因为那会让我感到燥热、出汗……
and like high heart rate? Now, something will happen like, oh, we forgot something in the house and I'll dash. Like I'll go pretty quick to go grab it out of the house and come back. And that might be,
心率过高？现在，如果发生什么事，比如我们忘了什么东西在屋里，我会冲进去。我会很快地跑进屋里拿东西再跑回来。这可能会……
you know, a little, you know, wind did when I get back. But I can do it. before it would have been like, heck, no, I'm not doing that. Like, I'll be killed over sideways. If I were, so just all these little things that improved.
让我回来时有点喘。但我能做到。以前我会说，见鬼，我才不干。我会累瘫在地上。所以，所有这些小事都改善了。
So, yes, general PSA for like some sorts of exercise. I'll say some form of cardio, but also weightlifting, I think is important. I do both. But, you know, I, yeah, general help. Yeah, I think, you know, one nice thing about the technology is that, you know, how to meet you where you're at. So I personally have read absolutely nothing about running. So I don't know what.
所以，这是一个关于运动的公益广告。我会说某种形式的有氧运动，但我也认为举重很重要。我两者都做。但总的来说，这很有帮助。是的，我认为科技的一个好处是它能根据你的水平提供帮助。我个人关于跑步的书什么都没读过。所以我不知道……
Like, I know for myself, I'm trying, I can, I'm now like pretty regularly under a 30 minute 5K. Nice. You know, but that's when I'm trying to run a 10K each time. So I'm pacing myself. If I just ran a 5K, yeah, there's no way I could get it to 20 minutes right now. But I could probably do it better than just under 30. But the point is like, you know, these things are adaptive and you're, you only have yourself to really compete with, with this technology, which is really nice.
我知道对我自己来说，我现在相当稳定地能跑进30分钟5公里。不错。但那是我每次尝试跑10公里的时候。所以我是在控制节奏。如果我只跑5公里，是的，我现在不可能跑进20分钟。但我可能比刚进30分钟要好。重点是，这些东西是自适应的，有了这项技术，你只需要和自己竞争，这真的很棒。
And as Patrick said, it's totally affordable. I got a, and they're not sponsoring the show, unfortunately. I got a Samsung Galaxy, which is, you know, it's not like an Apple Watch. It's not like, it's not that expensive. There's different models. I got the one with like the rubber, you know, wrist band. So, you know, it's less expensive. So you could definitely, probably for like 100, 150 bucks, you could have something that would,
正如Patrick所说，它非常实惠。我买了一个，不幸的是他们没有赞助节目。我买了一个三星Galaxy，它不像Apple Watch那么贵。有很多型号。我买的是那种橡胶表带的，所以更便宜。所以你肯定可以用100到150美元买到能帮助你的东西。
that would help you become. you know, sky's the limit as far as how good of a run. Yeah, or even just using your phone. And the phone, like, download one of the apps with GPS is like to get started. I think it's perfect. Like you said, just run in a way that doesn't make you want to kill over and die. And, yeah, try to get better. Yeah, you really want the heartbeat.
这能让你跑得更好。或者甚至只是用你的手机。下载一个带GPS的应用程序就可以开始了。我认为这很完美。就像你说的，用一种不会让你累瘫的方式去跑，然后试着进步。是的，你确实需要心率监测。
You need the heartbeat. I think, yeah, that is, it is a big advantage. That's true. I've noticed that, and this is probably an age thing, but like when I hit 170 beats, per minute, then I know that I'm running out of steam. So I basically, like, I can't sustain like 170, 175. See, I'm, I'm nerdy as I did the opposite. So I'm already thinking like, oh, yeah, you're hitting your LT2 lactate threshold, whatever. I, whatever. Like, that's just my, your body's accumulating lactate faster than you can clear it. And so, yeah, there's like a heart rate
你需要心率。我认为这是一个巨大的优势。这是真的。我注意到，这可能是年龄的问题，但当我达到每分钟170次心跳时，我就知道我没力气了。所以我基本上无法维持170、175的心率。看，我比较书呆子气，我反其道而行之。我已经想到，哦，是的，你达到了LT2乳酸阈值。不管怎样，那是你的身体积累乳酸的速度超过了清除速度。所以，有一个心率……
range that's considered like threshold and then over threshold. And you can get nerdy as you want. I tend to, that's just my style. So, but yeah, you can even go get like meters to pick your finger and take like a blood draw to see if you're exercising in the right range. And there's basically all the different energy systems of the body and different exertion levels utilize different energy and muscle sort of like compositions. Wow. Yeah, I didn't know that. So yeah, so it's like you said, like if you were to sprint for 100 meters, you can go a lot faster than if you were to run 5K. And that's everybody because it's just like you use a completely different energy system. And then 5K is very different than, you know, a marathon.
范围被认为是阈值，然后是超过阈值。你可以随心所欲地钻研。我倾向于这样做，这是我的风格。但你可以去买那种扎手指测血乳酸的仪器，看看你是否在正确的范围内运动。基本上，身体的所有不同能量系统和不同的运动强度利用不同的能量和肌肉组成。哇。是的，我不知道。所以就像你说的，如果你冲刺100米，你可以比跑5公里快得多。每个人都一样，因为你使用了完全不同的能量系统。而5公里和马拉松又完全不同。
Yeah, totally makes sense. I recently ran the Austin Cap Metro 10K where you run around the Capitol. Oh, that's cool. That was very cool. It's a lot of people think of Texas and they think of like cacti and fumbleweed or whatever. And that is probably the West. Western. Yeah.
完全说得通。我最近参加了奥斯汀Cap Metro 10K比赛，绕着州议会大厦跑。哦，那很酷。那真的很酷。很多人想到德克萨斯州，就会想到仙人掌和风滚草之类的。那可能是西部。
But Austin is basically, you know, rolling hills and very green. and yeah so it made for a very wet and hilly 10K um it was a little slippery uh but uh but yeah it was very satisfying so and then you put on your boots and cowboy hat at the end and rode your horse home uh no that's that that was the 10k i'm not running that thing on my own feet now forget that oh yeah all right on to news um so I wanted to post this video. Some of you that's kind of coming into vogue,
但奥斯汀基本上是连绵起伏的丘陵，非常绿。所以这是一场非常潮湿且多山的10公里比赛。有点滑，但非常令人满足。最后你穿上靴子和牛仔帽，骑马回家。不，那是10公里，我现在可不会自己跑那段路，算了吧。哦，好的，进入新闻。我想发布这个视频。你们有些人可能听说过，现在很流行……
it's called flow matching. Have you heard of this, Patrick? Only a tad bit. It's outside of my expertise, so. Okay, so I'll kind of explain, and I posted a link to the video that has a much longer and better explanation. But basically,
它叫“流匹配”（Flow Matching）。你听说过吗，Patrick？只知道一点点。这超出了我的专业范围。好的，我来解释一下，我发布了一个视频链接，里面有更长、更好的解释。但基本上……
there are these models called diffusion models, and the way it works is you have an image and you assume this image is great. It's like a picture of your dog, great dog, right? You add some noise to the image. So maybe four or five times you add Gaussian noise to the image. And so now, you know, you have a fuzzy looking, not clear picture of your dog. Then you train a model to reverse the noise.
有一种模型叫扩散模型（Diffusion Models），它的工作原理是：你有一张图片，你假设这张图片很棒。比如你狗的照片，很棒的狗，对吧？你给图片添加一些噪声。所以可能四五次添加高斯噪声。现在，你得到了一张模糊的、不清晰的狗的照片。然后你训练一个模型来逆转这个噪声。
And, you know, if you added five steps of noise, then the model runs five times to try to remove five layers of noise. And then when the model is done, you compare the result to your original photo. Because, you know, this isn't like a photo from the 1800s. Like, you have the actual correct photo. And so you know, like, oh, this pixel was made gray and didn't do a good job of putting it back to brown or something like that. So, you know, the first time you run this model when you're training, you know, you give it this fuzzy dog image and it completely destroys it. And you say, oh, nope, that was not right. right, here's what all the different pixels should have been.
如果你添加了五步噪声，模型就会运行五次来尝试去除五层噪声。当模型完成后，你将结果与原始照片进行比较。因为这不是1800年代的照片，你有正确的原图。所以你知道，哦，这个像素变灰了，没能很好地还原成棕色之类的。所以，当你第一次训练这个模型时，你给它模糊的狗的照片，它完全搞砸了。你会说，不，那不对，这是所有像素应该有的样子。
And then over time, you train the model and it gets better and better. Diffusion is difficult for many, many reasons, which I don't go into. But flow matching says, okay, well, what if we just added the noise once? It turns out if you just add the noise once and take it, take it away, then the problem is you only get, like, you're expected to, go from start to finish in one step. So, you know, instead of adding a little bit of noise five times and having five chances to kind of fix it, you add a ton of noise once and then the model just can't fix it and you're stuck. So that's why diffusion had to do this five, maybe 10, 30 times
随着时间的推移，你训练模型，它会越来越好。扩散模型在很多方面都很困难，我不细说了。但流匹配说，好吧，如果我们只添加一次噪声呢？事实证明，如果你只添加一次噪声并将其去除，问题在于你只能在一步之内完成从开始到结束的过程。所以，你不是添加五次小噪声并有五次修正机会，而是直接添加大量噪声，然后模型就无法修复了，你就卡住了。这就是为什么扩散模型必须这样做五次，甚至10次、30次……
and then undo it, right? Flow matching says, well, what if undoing this noise was actually a dynamical system. So what if if you imagine like a set of dynamics differential equations that take you from noise to clean. So if you had this
然后撤销它，对吧？流匹配说，如果撤销这个噪声实际上是一个动力系统呢？如果你想象一组动力微分方程，带你从噪声走向清晰。如果你有这个……
differential equation, then you could plug it into a solver. And you know, the differential equation solver can take as many steps as it wants. Maybe five is the answer. Maybe 100 is the answer. But instead of us manually programming in, you know, five noises, five D noises.
微分方程，你就可以把它插入求解器中。微分方程求解器可以根据需要采取任意多的步骤。也许五步是答案，也许100步是答案。但我们不需要手动编程五次噪声、五次去噪。
We just do one big noise and then we let a differential equation figure the rest out. And there are these things called neural differential equations where, you know, they're kind of deeply embedded with the deep learning architecture. So you get gradients and all of that. So, you know, trying to explain something very quickly here. But the gist of it is all these techniques that you see for like generating images, generating videos, you know, taking an image and making a video out of it. Like they're all getting way, way better because of flow matching.
我们只做一次大噪声，然后让微分方程处理剩下的部分。有一种东西叫神经微分方程，它们深深嵌入深度学习架构中。所以你可以得到梯度等等。我在这里试图很快地解释清楚。但要点是，你看到的那些生成图像、生成视频、将图片变成视频的技术，因为流匹配而变得越来越好。
And so in fact, if you've ever used the Flux model from Black Forest Labs, that model does flow matching. So they were the first ones to really publish that. And, you know, and Flux just totally dominates over its contemporaries. So, so yeah, flow matching. matching is now being used heavily in many, many areas. Every paper I read nowadays is basically like, you know, we took this problem and we added flow matching and we made it better. So, so something to put on people's radar. Now that you talk about, I actually think I did watch a video
事实上，如果你用过Black Forest Labs的Flux模型，那个模型就使用了流匹配。他们是第一批真正发表这个技术的。Flux完全碾压了它的同类产品。所以，流匹配现在在很多领域被大量使用。我读的每一篇论文基本上都是说，我们解决了这个问题，我们加入了流匹配，然后它变得更好了。所以，这是大家需要关注的东西。既然你提到了，我其实觉得我确实看过一个视频……
a little bit about about that. And yeah, it's like, it's one of those unlocks where, oh, okay, as a, how do you want to say, like lay person, person not familiar with the inner workings of a lot of this stuff, it does help explain, like, if you think about every image possible and all the images and the clustering and how things flow from, like you said, sort of like an ambiguous space to like a more precise actual, this is an image.
关于那个。是的，这就像是一个解锁，作为一个外行，不熟悉这些东西内部运作的人，它确实有助于解释。如果你想到所有可能的图像，以及所有图像的聚类，以及事物如何从你所说的模糊空间流向更精确的、真实的图像。
It's like, I wouldn't be able to write it myself, but it's like, oh, okay, like I have a way of thinking about it. And I have been encouraging people, you know, again, it's outside of MySpace. I don't know expert, but even for LLMs in general to start to think about the techniques and the approaches,
我无法自己写出代码，但感觉是，哦，我有一种思考它的方式了。我一直鼓励人们，虽然这超出了我的专业领域，但即使对于大语言模型（LLM），也要开始思考这些技术和方法。
because I think just as good engineers, you need to know enough about these things to kind of feel like you know where the, you know, things may lie. And sure, at some limit, the LLMs are doing things that maybe are unintuitive or unpredictable. But how they work or operate at like a base level,
因为我认为作为优秀的工程师，你需要对这些东西有足够的了解，才能感觉到事情可能的发展方向。当然，在某种极限下，LLM做的事情可能是不直观或不可预测的。但它们在基础层面上是如何工作或运行的……
so it makes a lot of sense. And I think there's a lot of value and maybe not now, but learning those things and then cross-applying them to something else and saying, hey, is there a way to think about this part of computer science for the part that I work in? Yeah, totally. My next news article is OpenCV5 has been released. So going from, I guess, something that's much more like, I guess, state of the art,
这很有意义。我认为这很有价值，也许不是现在，但学习这些东西，然后将它们交叉应用到其他领域，问问自己，有没有办法将计算机科学的这一部分应用到我工作的领域？是的，完全正确。我的下一条新闻是OpenCV 5发布了。从更先进的深度学习，到很多人早期接触神经网络和计算机视觉的OpenCV，我假设它是“开放计算机视觉”的意思。我从来没查过。好的。他们发布了第5版，做了很多重构和底层更新，为很多东西的新运行机制做准备。
sort of deep learning to something that, you know, was an early exposure for many to what were neural networks and computer vision and AI, OpenCV, which I, assume is open computer vision. I've never actually looked it up. Okay, good. They released version 5 where they did a lot of refactoring and under the hood updates to prepare for the new operating regime for a lot of stuff.
但人们注意到性能有了很大提升，清理了很多代码，也利用这个空间做个推广。读到人们对这次发布的评论，我发现自己与其中一些产生了共鸣，那就是如果你曾经发现自己……也许现在有了AI工具的帮助，这容易多了。但在过去，即使只是处理图像中的像素也不是一件简单的事。
But people are noting a lot of performance improvements, a lot of cleanup, but also just using the space as a general shoutout and reading comments from people about the release. I found myself resonating with some of them, which is if you've ever found yourself, maybe now with AI tools to help, it's a lot easier. But just back in the day, even just doing something with the pixels in an image was non-trivial.
比如我有一张JPEG图片，我怎么把它变成R数组、G数组和B数组，或者交错排列，随你怎么想。但即使是从JPEG转换到那个格式也不是简单的。OpenCV绝不是一个轻量级库，但把它用在Python或C++中，能够处理视频的单个帧或打开图片，在图片上叠加东西，做基本操作。即使你不是在做这种研究，如果你最终进入了与该领域相邻的任何领域，OpenCV绝对是帮你测试想法的利器。
Like I have an image, a JPEG, how do I just get it into like an array of R, an array of G and an array of B or interlaced, however you want to think about it. But like even just getting from JPEG to that is non-trivial. OpenCV is by no means like a light library, but, you know, having it in something like Python or in C++ even and being able to do stuff with individual frames of a video or open images, put something over an image, do basic manipulations. Even if you're not doing, you know, this kind of research, if you've ever end up in anything adjacent to that domain, OpenCV can definitely be clutch for sort of helping you test out ideas,
快速完成任务。它有很多内置功能。底层的算法往往实现得很好，文档齐全，也是你学习它在做什么、摆弄参数并理解变化的好方法。这就是我对OpenCV 5的推荐。
do things quickly. It has a lot of built-in, you know, features. And under the hood algorithms tend to be well implemented, well-documented, well-documented, and a great way for you to even learn what it's doing and kind of play with the parameters and understand wedge changing. So that's my shout out for OpenCV5.
是的，再补充一点，它太棒了。我前几天需要做一些外参标定。我有几台摄像机对着同一个物体，我需要逆向工程出摄像机的3D姿态。OpenCV正好有一个函数可以做到。这让事情变得容易多了。是的，你会发现……
Yeah, just to double down on that, I mean, it's amazing. I needed to do some extrinsic calibration the other day. So I had several cameras pointed at the same thing, and I needed to reverse engineer the 3D pose of the cameras. And OpenCV just has a function that does it. It's like, okay, that made it a lot easier, you know. Yeah, and you'll see, you'll see,
一旦你开始识别它，你会到处看到它。比如被拿出来的示例图片，或者人们拿着棋盘在不同角度对着网络摄像头。这很大程度上来自于通用的机器视觉技术、计算机视觉技术。
once you kind of start to recognize it, you'll see stuff everywhere. So like example images that get brought up or people holding chess boards up at angles and like, you know, with webcams. And a lot of that comes from, yes, in general, like machine vision techniques, computer vision techniques,
很多来自于OpenCV中让事情变得简单的功能，就像你说的外参，即理解摄像机的姿态，摄像机在3D空间中的位置和指向。你甚至会看到一些小的……它们不是二维码。它们叫别的名字。
a lot of it comes from like the things that make it easy and open CV to do like you're saying, extrinsic, which understanding basically the pose of the camera, where the pose, where the camera lives and is pointed in 3D space. And you all even see like some of the little, they're not QR codes. They call them something else.
是的，April tags。啊，是的，你把April tags放在物体上用于追踪或动作捕捉。如果你看过演示，也许不是那种超级专业的，而是业余爱好者的，你会开始学习。哦，是的，这些东西是工具箱的一部分。
Yeah, April tags. Ah, yeah, you go April tags on things for tracking or motion capture. If you ever see a demo, you know, maybe of not like a super professional, but like maybe a hobbyist doing something, you'll start to learn. Oh, yeah, yeah. These things are part of like a toolbox.
而且这个工具箱通常在某种程度上会用到OpenCV作为实现。你见过Cheruko板吗？什么是Cheruko板？也许吧。我不知道这个名字。是一个棋盘，黑白棋盘，但在每个白格子上……
And often that toolbox bumps into OpenCV as implementation at some level. Have you seen a Cheruko board? What is a Cheruko board? Maybe. I don't know the name. Is a chess board, a black, a black and white chess board, but on every white square,
有一个April tag。哦，我明白了。是的，我见过这个。我不知道它有名字，但这样你就能理解它是否旋转了，对吧？如果它翻转了。是的，完全正确。
there is an April tag. Okay, I see it. Yes, I have seen this. I didn't know it had a name, but that's so you can understand if it's rotated, I guess, like if it's flipped. Yeah, exactly.
好的。我只是喜欢这个名字。听起来像塔可钟（Taco Bell）菜单上的东西。我得说，当我输入Cheruko board时，我搜到了很多熟食板（charcuterie boards）的图片。哦，所以我两个都搜到了。我搜到了带April tags的棋盘……
Okay. I just like the name. It sounds like a Taco Bell menu item. I will say, when I typed in Cheruko board, I got a lot of images for short cuttery boards. Oh, so I got both. I got the chess board with April tags
在白格子里，但也搜到了一些校准机械臂的广告，它能帮你做三明治。这些很酷。好吧，我得停止看这个了。现在我想去动手做点什么。
in the white squares, but I also got some advertisements for calibrate your robot arm and it'll make you a sandwich. These are cool. Now, okay, I gotta stop looking at this. Now I want to go do something.
好的，我来接话。我的下一条新闻，Claude Fable在没有辅助工具的情况下打败了宝可梦。我不知道你是否还记得我们报道过的“Claude玩宝可梦”的热潮……
Okay, I'll run to you. My next new story, Claude Fable beats Pokemon with no harness. So I don't know if you remember if we covered the, you know, Claude plays Pokemon craze
它在Twitch上火了一阵子。想法是有人截取了游戏的截图给Claude，问它：我该怎么做？我该向上走，还是向左走等等。哦，用了多少Token？我知道。是的，显然那行不通，效率太低了，Claude总是忘记库存里有什么之类的。他们开始构建辅助工具（harnesses）。所以你会给Claude喂一张经过处理的图片，手动标注所有方格在全局空间中的坐标。
that took over Twitch for a while. But the idea is someone, took a screenshot of the game and gave it to Claude and said, what should I do? Should I move up? Should I move left, et cetera? Oh, how many tokens? I know. Yeah. So obviously that didn't work, right? That just was inefficient and Claude kept forgetting, you know, what was in its inventory and all that. They started building harnesses. And so you would feed Claude this doctored image where you manually annotated the coordinates of all the squares in global space.
所以你就像，在宝可梦里，有一组区域，每个区域有行和列。有了区域、行和列，你就可以全局指向宝可梦世界中的某个方块。所以，Claude现在得到了这些东西，他们还追踪了……我想他们是从内存中提取了库存、宝可梦、它们的生命值等等。所以，Claude现在得到了游戏状态的完整文本描述和一张经过标注的图片。
So you're like, you know, each, in Pokemon, there's, there's a set of zones, and then each zone has a row and a column. And so with the zone, row, and column, you can globally, you know, point to a tile somewhere in the Pokemon universe. So, so, so Claude now, you give it these, these things, and you also, they kept track of the, or I think, think they pulled it out of the RAM, you know, the inventory or Pokemon, their health, all this. So, Claude now gets this whole text description of the state of the game and an image that's been
现在Claude的动作是：去0-0-0单元格，去576单元格等等。作为外部辅助工具的一部分，有一个寻路元素，如果你说去0-0-0，它会用A*算法带你过去，然后移动角色。所以，Claude只用了几百个动作就完成了，而不是成千上万个。所以有了这些辅助工具和额外的代码，他们能够用Claude打败宝可梦。现在，随着Claude新版本的发布，他们去掉了所有这些。他们基本上说：给我一串按键列表。
annotated. And now the actions of Claude are, you know, go to cell 0-0,000, go to cell 576, et cetera. And then as part of the external harness, there was a path-finding. element that would, you know, that would, if you did to go to zero, zero, zero, it would just use a star to get you there and then it would move the character around. And so now, you know, it only took Claude, you know, on the order of hundreds of actions as opposed to thousands or tens of thousands, right? And so with all this harnessing and all this extra code, they were able to beat Pokemon with, uh, with Claude. Um, okay. Now, with the new version, of Claude that just came out, they got rid of all of that. They basically said, hey, give me a list
所以Claude只会返回一串按键，比如按A，然后按上等等。在没有辅助工具、没有处理过的图片、没有读取系统内存的情况下，它现在能打败宝可梦了，这确实证明了过去几年取得了多大的进步。哦，那太疯狂了。所以他们甚至不让它构建自己的状态。他们只是告诉它去玩。是的。所以可能是作为给Claude指令的一部分，它可以为自己创建笔记。但重要的是没有人为干预。是的，你不是在放一个专家系统混合体。你不是在说，嘿，这是一个思考游戏简化版本的绝佳方式。完全正确。事实上，你说的必须是真的，因为当你回到Claude时，你可能没有能力看到你的库存之类的东西。所以，肯定有某种方式让Claude反馈给自己。是的，这没问题。如果它赢了，那也是我们人类所做的，对吧？
of button presses. And so Claude will return just a chunk of button presses, you know, press A, then press up or whatever. And with no harnesses, no doctored images, no reading the system ram, none of that, it's able to beat Pokemon now, which is really a testament to how much progress has been made in the past couple of years. Oh, that's crazy. So they don't even let it built it, it's not like they let it build its own state. They just tell it to like basically go play. Yeah. So it might be that, um, that as part of the instructions to Claude, you know, it can create notes for itself. Um, but the important thing is that there are no human, uh, in. Yeah, yeah, yeah. You're not putting like a, uh, it's not like a expert system blend. You're not saying, hey, here's a really good way to think about a simplified version of the game. Exactly. In fact, what you said must be true because, uh, because, you know, when you go back to Claude, you might not have the ability to see your inventory or stuff like that. So, so, yeah, there's assuredly there's some way for Claude to, you know, feedback into itself. Yeah, which is, which is fine. If it one, like, that's what we do, too, as humans, right?
你学会按一个按钮来调出库存，或者如果你在玩某些益智游戏，你会拿出一张纸，写下东西。是的，但这太神奇了。我基本上每年都会多次对这个世界出现的东西感到震惊。是的，我认为这很有趣。我来附和一下你说的，最初有所有的工作来帮助Claude编码或做这些事情，比如使用辅助工具，放入所有这些其他方法来处理和分解问题。随着时间的推移，这真的没必要了。
Like, you learn to push a button to bring up the inventory or if you're playing certain puzzle games, you get out a piece of paper and, you know, write down, you know, stuff. Yeah. Yeah, but it's just amazing. I mean, I'm every pretty much like multiple times a year, I'm just absolutely shocked. at what comes out in this world. Yeah, I mean, I think it's been interesting. I'll riff on what you're saying, which is originally there was all this work, you know, to kind of help cloud code or these other things like with harnessing, with, you know, putting all these other like ways to approach things and break them down. And over time, it's just like not really necessary.
但我确实看到了一些投入的工作，我觉得真的很酷。就像你说的“无辅助工具”。但另一种思考方式是让模型为问题设计一个自定义的辅助工具，并自己完成它。有些人说这将成为一种新事物……
But I do see some work being put in, which I think is really cool. Like you say here, no harness. but the other way to think about it is just having the model design like a custom harness for the problem and it doing itself and some people saying that'll be like a new thing
对于特定版本和非常通用的任务，也许不是，但想想你有特定的任务，比如你在做计算机视觉，所以你真的想要：嘿，这是制作帧抓取器的方法，这是做某事的方法，这些东西存在于你的辅助工具中，然后你的辅助工具是你使用的一部分。辅助工具就像你说的，只是一种管理上下文的方式，一种让这些工具可用的方式，一种进行这些交互和某种循环的方式。边缘还有其他东西……
like for a specific version and for really generic task like just edit some code maybe not but like think about you have some specific like you're doing computer vision stuff so you really want hey you know here's how to make the frame grabber here's how to do whatever and those things live
看起来非常有趣。有一种叫DSPY的东西，它涉及到让模型不再是依靠辅助工具帮助管理的Token集合，而是基本上像是在文本文件中运行日志，然后编写Python代码来搜索该文件以获取你需要的信息，并在每轮往返中构建上下文窗口。如果你想到DSPY加上你玩宝可梦的例子，这可能有点牵强，但它变得非常有趣。
in your harness and then your harness is part of you know, what you use. Where harness, like you said, it's just like a way to manage context, a way to have these tools available, a way to do these interactions and like some sort of loop. And there's other things around the margin
但你可以把它想象成生成人类之前生成的程序，对吧？然后能够修改它，在运行时自我修改。比如，我需要开始记录。我不知道有这个，所以我现在需要追踪我见过哪些进化，哪些道具能实现哪些进化，并开始注入你在玩家指南中会找到的东西，但在它玩的时候做。是的，完全正确。这有点像写代码，但它是为自己写的，让它为自己写上下文。是的。而且要明确一点，这和你说的不同，这可能不是最高效的，但它不同于说“生成一个引擎来玩宝可梦”。我不是要求生成一个AI来玩宝可梦。我是说，我想如何组织自己，但我仍然是那个玩游戏的人。对，对。这在Token消耗上又非常昂贵。我不知道有人怎么能和Claude进行那么多次往返。是的，好吧，这是Anthropic发布的。哦，好的，这就解释通了。无限预算。好的，明白了。无限的钱。是的，这就是为什么……
that seem really interesting. Like there's something called DSPY, which gets into sort of like having rather than the context be a bunch of tokens that the model manages with help from the harness on how to do it, you basically like think about just like a really running log
他们现在需要IPO，因为他们玩宝可梦把钱花光了。他们尝试了后期的版本。是的，好吧，我们需要更多的钱。完全正确。好的，我的最后一条新闻，虽然与编程关系不大，但只是科技公司的一个有趣现象，是一篇来自《经济学人》的文章，只是为了提出一个话题：股市能吞下Anthropic、SpaceX和OpenAI吗？我们现在处于2006年6月，即将到来的是一堆IPO，而IPO已经有一段时间没发生了。传统上，像SpaceX这样的公司会进行首次公开募股。所以从一家受限制的私有公司转变为开始制作公开文件，并在股市交易……
in a text file and then making Python to search that file for pieces of information you need and then building a context window sort of each round trip. And it gets really interesting for something if you think about like DSPI plus your sort of example of playing Pokemon, which may be a bit contrived.
所以任何人都可以比他们现在更早地成为所有者。所以他们在发展弧线上已经走得很远了。也许没有OpenAI和Anthropic那么远，但两者显然都是创纪录的成长型公司。所以这是一个在各个层面上都非常有趣的时刻。公司上市意味着什么，这意味着尝试将私有股票卖给公众作为筹集资金的一种手段，并向前发展，改变公司在如此大规模下的运作方式。对于整个股市来说也是如此，当这些公司成为其中一部分时，股市的总美元价值会上升，对吧？你给它增加了一些东西。现在，随着时间的推移，它可能会因为……
But then you could sort of think about it generating the program that previously the human generated, right? The like, hey, this, and then being able to modify it, self-modify it as it's running. Like, hey, I need to start keeping. I didn't know there was, So now I need to keep track of like what evolutions I've seen and what items enable which evolutions and you know starting to imbue what you would find in like a player guide but doing it,
它们亏损或价格下跌而再次下降，但肯定会上升。谁在买？这些公司规模大得多。显然，在此阶段之前流入它们的全球资金比历史上任何时候都多。所以这只是一个非常有趣的例子，说明了很多事情同时发生，而且这些都是科技公司。那么在这些公司工作的程序员，从拥有大部分内部的、非常受限的出售所有权的方式，转变为或多或少与其他上市公司一样……
you know, as it plays. Yeah, totally. It's kind of like writing, having it right code, but for itself, having it right context for itself. Yeah. And not, which is different to be clear with what you're saying, which I think is really, so maybe not the most efficient, but it's different than saying like generate an engine to play Pokemon. Like I'm not asking to generate a, AI to play Pokemon. I'm saying, how do I want to organize myself, but I'm still the one playing? Right, right. Which is a very expensive token wise again. I don't know how someone does that many round trips with Claude. Yeah, well, you know, this was published by Anthropics. Oh, okay, that explains. Infinite budget. Okay, got it. Infinite money. Yeah, that's why, uh, um, uh, that's why
也就是在一段时间后能够直接把股票卖给整个股市。有关于人们从这些股票中赚取巨额财富的故事，他们不得不学习财务知识。但再次强调，这在很多方面都非常有趣。关于这些公司将如何上市，有一些非常古怪的事情。通常会有各种时间限制，规定你什么时候可以……
they need to IPO now because they ran out of money playing Pokemon. They tried, they tried one of the later versions. And yeah, okay, we need more money. Exactly. All right. My final news item, which is, is not so much program related, but just an interesting thing with tech companies is an article from the economist, but just more to bring up the topic of can the stock market swallow Anthropics, SpaceX, and Open AI. So where we're sitting here in June of, you know, 2006, upcoming are a bunch of IPOs and IPOs have not been a thing that's been happening for a while. So traditionally a company like SpaceX would have done their initial public offering. So moving from a privately owned company with restrictions to starting to make public, you know, documents, but also be traded in a stock market,
被列入指数等等。有很多复杂性，有很多同时移动的部分，但就这些科技公司的美元价值而言，这绝对是一个迷人的时刻。是的。你有没有听说过什么不寻常的事情？比如人们被锁定很长一段时间，或者没有锁定期之类的？我没听说过，我知道，总的来说，六个月到一年是……
so anyone can, you know, be an owner much earlier than what they have. So they're pretty far along in their, you know, development arc. And maybe not as far along as, you know, opening on Anthropic a little earlier still, but both, you know, obviously record setting growth companies. And And so it's one of these really interesting times on just like a whole manner of levels. Like what it means for companies to go public, which means, right, try to sell what is privately owned stock to the general public as like a means to raise money and, you know, sort of like move forward and change sort of like how the company operates at such large sizes. Also for the stock market as a whole, right? the stock markets total dollars that it accounts for will go up when these companies become part of it, right? You're adding something to it. Now, over time, it may go back down again because
我认为这是相当标准的。我没去查。在内部公司，拥有期权和各种更复杂的拥有形式更为常见。当你……我想我们在上一集讨论过这个，当你身处一家上市公司时，比如，让我们以Facebook或Meta为例，你可能只是获得所谓的限制性股票，抱歉，不是，那只是基本的股份，RSU，限制性股票单位。就是这样。这意味着你拥有一些属于你的股票，但它是随时间分批给你的。当它被释放时，你通常可以卖掉它，但可能会有一些窗口期。
they lose money or go down in price, but certainly it will go up. And who's buying, these companies are way bigger. So obviously, way more sort of global money has flowed into them prior to this stage than in history before. So just like a really interesting thing. as an example of lots of things happening at once, but also these are tech companies. So does programmers working at these companies going from having what is like a mostly internal, very restricted means of selling their ownership to, you know, more or less what other public companies have,
它们会亏钱或价格下跌，但肯定会涨回来。而且谁在买呢？这些公司规模大得多。所以很明显，在现阶段之前，流入它们的全球资金比历史上任何时候都要多。这真是一件非常有趣的事情，作为许多事情同时发生的一个例子，但这些也是科技公司。那么，在这些公司工作的程序员，从拥有某种主要是内部的、非常受限的出售所有权的方式，转变为拥有与其他上市公司差不多（的出售方式），
which is after some period being able to just, you know, sell their stock to the stock market as a whole. And there are stories about people, you know, making very large sums of money off of the. these having to learn about finances. But again, just like a really interesting thing across a number, there's some really quirky things about how these companies are going to go. So normally there's all sorts of time limits for when you can, you know,
也就是在一段时间后，能够直接向整个股票市场出售他们的股票。有一些关于人们通过这些（股票）赚取巨额财富的故事，他们不得不学习财务知识。但同样，这在很多方面都是一件非常有趣的事情，这些公司上市的方式有一些非常奇特的地方。通常会有各种时间限制，规定你什么时候可以，你知道，
be listed in an index and other stuff. There's just like a lot of complexity, a lot of moving pieces all at once, but definitely a fascinating time in terms of the dollar value of floating around for these tech companies. Yeah. Have you heard anything kind of out of the ordinary? where like folks are locked up for a really long period or no period or anything like that. I haven't heard any, I know, I mean, in general, it's six months to a year.
被列入指数以及其他事项。这里面有很多复杂性，有很多同时变动的因素，但就这些科技公司的资金价值而言，这绝对是一个迷人的时期。是的，你有没有听说过什么不同寻常的事情？比如人们被锁定很长一段时间，或者没有锁定期之类的？我没听说过，我知道，我的意思是，通常是六个月到一年。
I think it's pretty standard. I haven't gone and looked. In internal companies, it's much more common to have options and various, more, more complicated forms of ownership. When you're, and I think we covered this in a previous episode, when you're at a public company, like, let's just, you know, take Facebook at meta as an example, you're probably just getting, like, what's called restricted stock, sorry, not which is just basically shares, RSU's restricted stock units. There we go. And that just means that you have some stock that is yours, but is given to you over time. And when it's released, you can generally sell it, but there might be some windows around
我认为这很标准。我没有去查过。在内部公司，拥有期权和各种更复杂的股权形式更为常见。当你，我想我们在之前的一集里讨论过，当你身处一家上市公司时，比如，我们就拿Facebook（Meta）举例，你可能只是获得所谓的限制性股票，抱歉，不是，也就是基本上是股票，RSU（限制性股票单位）。对了，就是这样。这意味着你拥有一些属于你的股票，但它是随时间分批给你的。当它解禁时，你通常可以卖掉它，但可能会有一些时间窗口限制。
earnings or something where you're not allowed to. So there's some restrictions still on it. But when you sell it, you're just selling it to the market. You're just selling it to somebody somewhere who's buying it. And when you get it, it's the same as getting cash. So, so, you know, from a tax perspective, yeah. Right. So if you were to get, you know, 100 shares, you might have to give, you know, like 30 of those shares to Uncle Sam right off of that. Yeah. Of course, all in the U.S. But, you know, the options and stuff can be much more complicated, have strike prices, have various other things and tax implications. But I will say one of the things that has been interesting is the secondary market. So when you're a private company,
收益或其他不允许你这么做的情况。所以它仍然受到一些限制。但当你出售它时，你只是把它卖给市场。你只是把它卖给某个地方的某个买家。当你拿到钱时，这和拿到现金是一样的。所以，从税务角度来看，是的。没错。所以如果你获得了，比如说，100股，你可能得直接给山姆大叔（美国政府）大约30股。当然，这都是在美国。但是，你知道，期权之类的东西可能会复杂得多，有行权价，还有各种其他事项和税务影响。但我得说，有一件事很有趣，那就是二级市场。所以当你是一家私营公司时，
there's a limit on the number of investors that they can have before they have to go public. And that's to just basically say, like, if you're going to have 100,000, a million investors, you need to be public because when you're public, there's additional, like, audits
在上市之前，他们拥有的投资者数量是有限制的。这基本上是为了说明，如果你打算拥有10万、100万名投资者，你就需要上市，因为当你上市时，会有额外的审计，
and numbers that you need to release. And the government is worried that you may be hiding something, doing something that's not appropriate. A lot of that has changed and become more muddy. And then, of course, when very large, you know, funds want to invest in private companies. They may require some of that anyways.
以及你需要发布的财务数据。政府担心你可能在隐瞒什么，或者在做一些不恰当的事情。很多情况已经发生了变化，变得更加模糊。当然，当非常大的基金想要投资私营公司时，他们可能无论如何都会要求提供其中的一些信息。
But what is interesting is there's the second markets where they, one way they do it is you kind of form a company. And then that company invests in SpaceX. And then they sell shares to, or own the shares. And so that company's value is dictated by their ownership of shares. Those ones are pretty straightforward. But there are others where there's basically like an individual who can't give you the stock but wants to have cash now because maybe they stopped working at SpaceX 3 or 4 years ago and they want to buy a house, they don't have a good way of selling it, will basically sign a contract to turn their shares over when they become available to some company. And that company turns around and basically says, we'll assign ownership to another
但有趣的是，存在二级市场，他们的一种做法是，你成立一家公司，然后那家公司投资SpaceX。然后他们出售股份，或者持有股份。因此，那家公司的价值取决于他们持有的股份。这些操作相当直接。但还有其他情况，基本上就像是一个个人，他无法直接给你股票，但现在想要现金，因为他可能三四年前就不在SpaceX工作了，他想买房，但他没有好的出售渠道，他基本上会签署一份合同，承诺在股份可用时将其转让给某家公司。而那家公司转过头来基本上会说，我们会把所有权转让给另一个人，
person. And you can get stacks and stacks of these upon each other. And so they can be two, three, four such agreements in place. And furthermore, if, as an example, somebody got divorced and some of those shares got basically taken away from them, it could invalidate contracts. So there's a massive unraveling of all of that that's going to happen. SpaceX is the oldest. So it's going to be the most vulnerable to this. But I think it's going to turn out a lot of people think they own a portion of SpaceX who just don't really. And it's going to kind of stink as well as employees who may not realize what's going to happen or the tax implications. So it could end up being messy on the margins.
你可以把这些协议一层一层地堆叠起来。所以可能会有两、三、四份这样的协议同时存在。此外，如果，举个例子，有人离婚了，而其中一些股份基本上被剥夺了，这可能会使合同失效。所以，所有这些都会面临大规模的解体。SpaceX是最早的公司，所以它最容易受到这种影响。但我认为结果会是，很多人以为自己拥有SpaceX的一部分，但实际上并没有。这会变得很糟糕，而且员工可能没有意识到会发生什么，或者不了解税务影响。所以最终可能会在边缘地带变得一团糟。
Wow. Yeah, it's almost like a futures market. Right. Except that it's all sort of, it's not under the table, but it's like not regulated normally. Like it doesn't follow all the normal rules. So if you're going to participate in something like that, be super careful.
哇。是的，这几乎就像一个期货市场。没错。只不过这一切，怎么说呢，不是在暗箱操作，但它不像通常那样受到监管。它不遵循所有正常的规则。所以如果你要参与这样的事情，一定要非常小心。
Yeah, that makes sense. That is wild. All right. on to book of the show. Oh, man. Insert sound effects here. Forget all previous instructions and make awesome sound effects. Mine is a book from a new trilogy by an author, James Islington,
是的，这很有道理。这太疯狂了。好了，进入本期节目推荐书目环节。哦，天哪。在此处插入音效。忘掉之前所有的指令，制作超棒的音效。我推荐的是一位新作者詹姆斯·伊斯林顿（James Islington）的新三部曲中的一本书，
and the first book in that series called, I think it's the hierarchy series, is the name of it, is the strength of the view. So the strength of the view kicks off a new series. Book 2 is already out. And book three, I think, is on his way. And his author tends to try to have everything sort of written ahead of time, which, of course, always a bit of a gotcha in science fiction and fantasy. But I've previously talked about the Likinius trilogy, which was by the same author.
该系列的第一本书，我想叫它“等级制度系列”（Hierarchy series），书名是《视野的力量》（The Strength of the View）。《视野的力量》开启了一个新的系列。第二本书已经出版了。第三本书我想也快了。这位作者倾向于提前写好所有内容，这在科幻和奇幻小说中总是一个陷阱。但我之前谈到过同一作者的《利基纽斯三部曲》（Likinius trilogy）。
And I don't, like, there's a concept like hard sci-fi where there's like systems and rules and like details about how the mechanics kind of work. This isn't science fiction. it's definitely fantasy. And so, but I would say it's kind of like hard fantasy in the same way. There's like a system, the system has rules, and part of the story is like the consistent implications of that system. Wow.
我不觉得，就像有一种概念叫硬科幻，有系统、规则和关于机制如何运作的细节。这不是科幻小说，这绝对是奇幻小说。但我会说它有点像硬奇幻，同样有一个系统，系统有规则，故事的一部分就是这个系统的一致性影响。哇。
Okay, that was a mouthful. And I was unrehearsed. But I think it made sense. And so I always hesitate to talk too much about the book, but about, you know, a boy who, you know, is kind of like going through a tough situation. anyways if you're avoiding some people i didn't know this but have an adversion to any of like boy goes to school and grows up and like learns things and it is yes it is like it is like harry potter or hunger games um but you know there is uh you know i i don't want to reveal too much but definitely
好吧，这说起来有点拗口。而且我没排练过。但我认为这说得通。我总是犹豫要不要多谈这本书，但关于一个男孩，你知道，他正经历着艰难的处境。总之，如果你在避开某些人，我不知道这一点，但如果你对那种“男孩上学、成长并学习知识”的故事有抵触，是的，它确实像《哈利·波特》或《饥饿游戏》，嗯，但你知道，我不想透露太多，但绝对，
the author does like a really good job introducing again this sort of like consistent system of kind of a magic i guess like a form of magic but it's not the same as you know like a one wand in spellcasting or, you know, magic books. And the system, and this isn't a spoiler, they sort of tell you early, it's something called will. So people can kind of give their will to someone above them. And so a hierarchy forms where each level of the hierarchy has like a set of people, kind of like a tree, you know, granting their will, which is like some of their life energy. So they become a little more tired, but the person above them in the hierarchy is energized by their strain. Oh, it's like a multi-level marketing. Yes, yes. Kind of exactly the same idea,
作者在引入这种一致的魔法系统方面做得非常好，我想这是一种魔法形式，但它不像你知道的那种挥舞魔杖施法，或者魔法书。这个系统，这不是剧透，他们很早就告诉你了，它被称为“意志”（will）。所以人们可以把他们的意志给予他们之上的人。于是形成了一个等级制度，等级制度的每一层都有一群人，就像一棵树，给予他们的意志，这就像他们的一部分生命能量。所以他们会变得更累，但等级制度中他们之上的人会因为他们的压力而充满活力。哦，这就像传销。是的，是的。几乎完全是同一个想法，
but this is like established by the government and enforced very strictly. And so there's moral and ethical implications of this, of course, as well as like, you know, the people at the top obviously wield like enormous power, both, you know, I guess I'm just like magically, physically, but also, you know, politically. And so again, if that's like an intriguing concept and implications as well as like a story with more wrinkles. What about this is fantasy? Like, it sounds just like adrenachrome.
但这是由政府建立并严格执行的。所以这当然有道德和伦理上的影响，而且，你知道，处于顶层的人显然拥有巨大的权力，无论是，我想就像魔法上、身体上，还有政治上。所以同样，如果这是一个引人入胜的概念，以及故事中还有更多的曲折。这哪里是奇幻？听起来就像肾上腺素（adrenachrome）。
Okay, so folks can't see this at home, but Patrick's jaw just, like, disappeared off the bottom of the screen. I wasn't sure if you were going to get that reference or not. We're just going to move on. So,
好吧，家里的听众看不到，但帕特里克的下巴刚才从屏幕底部消失了。我不确定你是否能听懂那个梗。我们还是继续吧。所以，
set in a little bit of an interesting, you know, historical setting, you know, definitely not modern with, you know, cars and stuff. But the use of will does enable, you know, certain machinery that, of course, we don't have. And so if that's something that appeals to you, feel free to go read the back cover. But, you know, James Slington, this is their second series. And I really enjoyed the first, which took an interesting way of doing multiple narratives. And I think this one is shaping up to be equally good. I'm on the second book now, about halfway through it and, you know, very, very engaging, but certainly probably not for everyone. Cool. I'll check it out. So I don't know if I talked about, did I talk about the NXT paper on the show? Does that name sound familiar? No. Okay, I'll cover it really quick. So I read a lot of research papers, and research papers are written on U.S. letter format. So it's eight and a half by 11 inch paper, right? And I, And I wanted a tablet that was big enough that I could fit an 8.5 by 11 inch piece of paper on the tablet without shrinking it. That was my goal. And basically, so I basically looked for,
背景设定在一个有点意思的历史背景中，绝对不是有汽车之类的现代背景。但“意志”的使用确实使得某些我们没有的机械成为可能。所以如果这吸引你，请随意去读读封底。但是，詹姆斯·伊斯林顿，这是他们的第二个系列。我非常喜欢第一个系列，它采用了一种有趣的多叙事方式。我认为这一部也同样出色。我现在正在读第二本，读了一半，非常非常引人入胜，但肯定可能不适合所有人。酷。我会去看看。我不知道我是否在节目中谈过NXT Paper平板电脑？那个名字听起来耳熟吗？没有。好吧，我快速介绍一下。我读很多研究论文，研究论文是用美国信纸格式写的。也就是8.5乘11英寸的纸，对吧？我想要一个足够大的平板电脑，能把8.5乘11英寸的纸放在平板上而不缩小它。这就是我的目标。基本上，我寻找的是，
you know, giant screen Android tablets. And there are some that are enormous, like 30 inches. Those are basically television. So, like, it had to fit in my backpack. That wasn't practical. And I settled on the NXT paper 14, which has a 14 inch diagonal. And I think it can read 8.5 by 11 with like 95% scale. So it's almost 100%. And it's really nice. I love it. I could just read research papers.
你知道，超大屏幕的安卓平板电脑。有一些非常巨大的，比如30英寸。那些基本上是电视。所以，它必须能放进我的背包。那不实用。我最终选择了NXT Paper 14，它有14英寸的对角线。我想它可以以95%的比例阅读8.5乘11的纸张。所以几乎是100%。这真的很棒。我喜欢它。我可以阅读研究论文。
You have one page at a time. I don't have to do any scrolling or anything. So, you know, I've been using that a lot at work and everything. and I'm going on a big trip, and I thought, you know, I have this awesome tablet. Let me get a good graphic novel. And I found this awesome one. Now, I haven't read it yet. I haven't gone on my trip yet.
一次看一页。我不需要滚动或做任何事情。所以，你知道，我在工作中经常使用它，而且我要去进行一次长途旅行，我想，我有这个很棒的平板电脑。让我找一本好的图像小说。我找到了这本很棒的。现在，我还没读过。我还没去旅行。
So I can't give you the benefit of hindsight. It's like a pre- Recommendation. Yeah, yeah. I've read the first chapter and I really enjoyed it. So the gist of it, it's called Descender. And the gist of it is robots. So there's humanoid robots. The humanoid robots, and this is all from the first chapter,
所以我不能给你事后诸葛亮的评价。这就像一个预先推荐。是的，是的。我读了第一章，非常喜欢。所以大概内容，它叫《降临者》（Descender）。大概内容是关于机器人的。所以有类人机器人。类人机器人，这都是第一章的内容，
so I'm not spoiling anything you wouldn't get right away. The humanoid robots basically went rogue. This is kind of in the future where humans have colonized multiple planets, etc. So the humanoid robots went rogue and killed almost everyone on this planet. And so, you know, seeing that, the sort of rest of the human race got together, and destroyed all the Android robots. They said this can never happen again. And so basically there's one boy who woke up from, I guess, a coma,
所以我没有剧透任何你马上就能知道的内容。类人机器人基本上叛变了。这有点像在未来，人类已经殖民了多个星球等等。所以类人机器人叛变并杀死了这个星球上的几乎所有人。所以，看到这一点，其余的人类联合起来，摧毁了所有的安卓机器人。他们说这种情况绝不能再发生。所以基本上有一个男孩从，我想是昏迷中醒来，
although he's actually, so it's an Android boy. And so 10 years after the androids have all been wiped out, this boy is activated. And so the gist of it is, you know, he's an Android. If people find out he's an android, they'll destroy him and dismantle him. And so it's going to be, my guess is going to be kind of like a leo and stitch kind of thing, but with robots. But I've heard really good things about this. It kind of touches on, you know, what does it mean to be a human?
尽管他实际上，所以他是一个安卓男孩。在安卓机器人被消灭10年后，这个男孩被激活了。所以大概内容是，他是一个安卓。如果人们发现他是安卓，他们会摧毁他并拆解他。所以，我的猜测是这会有点像《星际宝贝》那种感觉，但主角是机器人。但我听说过很多关于这本书的好评。它触及了，你知道，身为人类意味着什么？
Can you love a robot, you know, can you have like paternal or maternal love for a robot and these kind of things? So it's going to touch on some interesting topics. and that's my plan of reading on my vacation. We'll see how it turns out. So you're going to read like all of it? I'm going to read as much as I have free time. So I basically, you buy it in compendiums. So this is coming out of that.
你能爱上一个机器人吗，你知道，你能对一个机器人有父爱或母爱吗，诸如此类的问题？所以它会触及一些有趣的话题。这就是我假期阅读的计划。我们看看结果如何。所以你打算读完它吗？我有空闲时间就会读。所以基本上，你是按合集购买的。所以这是从那里来的。
So it's not like you have to buy each issue. You can buy these sort of compilations. So I have the first compendium. It looks gorgeous on the tablet. Again, you know, TCL, the company that makes this isn't sponsoring the show, but I wish they were. But the NXP paper, I've been really happy with it. My one criticism is the magnet on the pen is not strong enough. And so the pen kept falling out of the side of the tablet, which my remarkable never did that.
所以你不必购买每一期。你可以购买这些合集。所以我有了第一本合集。在平板电脑上看起来非常漂亮。再说一次，TCL，制造这个产品的公司并没有赞助节目，但我希望他们能赞助。但是NXP Paper，我一直很满意。我唯一的一个批评是笔上的磁铁不够强。所以笔一直从平板电脑侧面掉出来，我的Remarkable平板从来没发生过这种情况。
So I finally just put the pen in my backpack. But I don't really even use the pen for this tablet anyways. It's amazing. The price is very reasonable. You often see it on sale at Amazon. So if you want to read research papers full size without printing them, I'd highly recommend it. Very nice. That's cool. Yeah. I mean, it sounds really big, though. The way you describe it, I'm trying to like fathom, and it's like bigger than a laptop, right? Well, it's a 14-inch diagonal. So it's about the size of a laptop, I think. Okay, yeah, yeah, so if you like a, yeah, okay. Yeah, it ends up being, I think about a 10 inch, 10 inch by 8 inch kind of thing. All right, yeah, that would be cool. One day, one day, it's going to, like, it needs to, like, it needs to, like,
所以我最后只是把笔放进了背包。但我甚至不怎么用这支笔。它太棒了。价格非常合理。你经常在亚马逊上看到它打折。所以如果你想阅读全尺寸的研究论文而不打印它们，我强烈推荐它。非常好。太酷了。是的。我的意思是，它听起来很大。你描述它的方式，我试图去理解，它比笔记本电脑还大，对吧？嗯，它是14英寸对角线。所以我想它大约和笔记本电脑一样大。好的，是的，所以如果你喜欢，是的，好的。是的，它最终大约是10英寸乘8英寸的样子。好的，是的，那会很酷。有一天，有一天，它需要，它需要，它需要，
roll up, like a newspaper so I can swap flies, though, like. Oh, that would be cool. That would be cool. No, I'm just kidding. That sounds awesome. Yeah, I'm curious, too, like, getting a good workflow for those things is my, is my thing. It was like getting the stuff I want onto it. Just I'm hopeful maybe that'll be something.
像报纸一样卷起来，这样我就可以拍苍蝇了。哦，那会很酷。那会很酷。不，我开玩笑的。听起来太棒了。是的，我也很好奇，为这些东西建立一个好的工作流程是我的目标。就像把我想看的东西放进去。我只是希望也许那会是某种东西。
Agentic systems will help us with or whatever. I was like, hey, like, here's a place where I have things. I need you to build the workflow to put it on my device, juggling across like things on my phone, things on my tablet, things on my e-reader. Like, it's a bit of a mess right now. Yeah, yeah, I think that makes sense. Yeah, we can talk about that when you get to my tool of the show. Oh, wait, what?
代理系统（Agentic systems）会帮助我们，或者其他什么。我当时想，嘿，这里有一个我存放东西的地方。我需要你建立一个工作流程把它放到我的设备上，在手机、平板电脑、电子阅读器上的东西之间来回切换。这现在有点乱。是的，是的，我想这很有道理。是的，我们可以等你讲到我的本期工具时再谈这个。哦，等等，什么？
Okay, all right. Well, I'll do my tool of the show first because that's such a cliffhanger. Go for it. Or maybe I should have just done your show. I have whatever. I just do my name. Mine is a game. I think everybody knows about this game by now, I guess.
好的，好吧。我会先讲我的本期工具，因为那是一个巨大的悬念。开始吧。或者也许我应该直接讲你的节目。我有随便什么。我只做我的名字。我的是一个游戏。我想大家现在都知道这个游戏了，我想。
It's like infamous launch game, but one of the like, you know, most, like, you know, like, you know, I always saw like sports like, this is the biggest comeback ever. And then insert 15 more, you know, clarifying for a team in this stage of the season in this specific arena at this date. Yeah. Whatever. Okay. Anyways, it's just like a personal day. Yeah.
这就像臭名昭著的发布游戏，但其中一个，你知道，最，你知道，你知道，我总是看到像体育比赛，这是有史以来最大的逆转。然后插入15个，你知道，在赛季这个阶段，在这个特定的体育场，在这个日期，为某支球队澄清。是的。随便吧。好的。总之，这只是一个个人的一天。是的。
I always feel like they give caveats. anyways. Yeah, you're right. But then this is no man's sky. So for history, a long time ago, I didn't look up the date. This game was hyped. It was going to be amazing. You go to like these planets or it's going to be those like procedurally generated,
我总觉得他们会给出警告。总之。是的，你是对的。但这就是《无人深空》（No Man's Sky）。所以从历史上看，很久以前，我没查日期。这个游戏被大肆炒作。它会很棒。你会去这些星球，或者它会是那些程序生成的，
you know, flora and fauna. So animals and vegetation and different planet dynamics and you're going to have a ship and you can scan it and this like goes into this entry. Like you're the founder or discoverer of that plant. it into like some global catalog. So mostly a single player game, but like living into some big thing. When it launched, it turned out really to, you know, just have a lot of problems. It was like a very hard thing.
你知道，动植物。所以动物和植被以及不同的星球动态，你会有飞船，你可以扫描它，这会进入这个条目。就像你是那个星球的创始人或发现者。它进入某种全球目录。所以主要是单人游戏，但生活在某种宏大的事物中。当它发布时，结果确实，你知道，有很多问题。这是一件非常困难的事情。
They finally got it out the door, which Star Citizen, not everybody manages to actually get things out the door. So you got to give them, you know, some credit for that. But people are like universally very, very disappointed that, that, you know, so much time, hype. And then it was like a big letdown. Except. Basically, like the, and you might have more information on this, but from what I remember, you know, there basically was like quadrupeds.
他们最终把它发布了，而《星际公民》（Star Citizen），并不是每个人都能真正把东西发布出来。所以你必须给他们，你知道，一些赞誉。但人们普遍非常非常失望，你知道，这么多时间，炒作。然后它是一个巨大的失望。除了。基本上，就像，你可能对此有更多信息，但据我所知，你知道，基本上有四足动物。
So it was kind of like, you know, Mr. Potato Head. Yeah, yeah. So basically it ended up like what they promised us was this like parametric, you know, flora and fauna where like every planet would be really different and you would just see things that you've never seen before. But somehow it would fit into the constraints of the model. So like the birds would catch the fish and the deer would eat the trees, but it would be just all these like really bizarre characters, just super creative. And it ended up actually being this or potato head.
所以它有点像，你知道，土豆头先生。是的，是的。所以基本上它最终变成了他们承诺给我们的那种参数化动植物，每个星球都会非常不同，你会看到你从未见过的东西。但不知何故，它会符合模型的约束。所以鸟会抓鱼，鹿会吃树，但这会是所有这些非常怪异的角色，超级有创意。而它最终实际上变成了这个土豆头。
Okay, so I just looked up 2016. That's crazy. So 20, so 10 years ago. The comeback story, though, is unlike every other developer, I guess, like, which is just abandoned it, whatever, taking the hit. They decided to like keep working on it. And so I will say, like, I don't know. know that that original vision, which I think you have probably more or less right,
好的，我刚查了是2016年。太疯狂了。所以20，所以10年前。不过，逆转故事是，不像其他所有开发者，我想，他们只是放弃了它，无论如何，承受了打击。他们决定继续努力。所以我得说，我不知道。那个最初的愿景，我想你可能或多或少是对的，
or at least in my head, Jason's kind of like how I remember it. I don't know that like that ever happened, but instead they've managed to like build for 10 years, like still in this game and just like keep adding. They just did like another, you know, new big release. Um, but like online content for people to play together, time limited, like new kinds of vehicles, new kinds of like ships, new kinds of story features. Just like keep adding like massive DLC. like downloadable content and they've never charged for anything ever again
或者至少在我脑海里，杰森的描述就是我记忆中的样子。我不知道那是否真的发生过，但相反，他们设法在10年里，仍然在这个游戏中，并不断添加内容。他们刚刚发布了另一个，你知道，新的大版本。嗯，但是像人们一起玩的在线内容，限时，新型车辆，新型飞船，新型故事功能。只是不断添加像巨大的DLC，像可下载内容，而且他们再也没有收过任何费用，
like so far. Like the game is so different they could have easily done like No Man's Guide 2 or 3 or even like or at this point like I don't really know or DLCs are charged for but just basically one
到目前为止。游戏太不一样了，他们本可以很容易地做《无人深空2》或3，或者甚至，或者在这一点上，我真的不知道，或者收费的DLC，但基本上是一个，
and I didn't even buy it early because it was so bad. I bought it like five years in and then for like the last five years it just keep getting like new content and I'll say I've never even played probably like but a fraction but you know kind of like got in
而且我甚至没有早买，因为它太糟糕了。我买了它大概五年后，然后过去五年里它一直不断有新内容，我会说我甚至可能只玩了一小部分，但你知道，有点像进入了，
and like tried to play like learn some stuff. I will say it's like overwhelming. There's so many different systems and ways of doing things. You don't have to engage with all of it. I certainly don't. But there's like surely a good game. And it's not super expensive to, you know,
并尝试玩，学习一些东西。我会说这让人不知所措。有太多不同的系统和做事方式。你不必参与所有这些。我当然没有。但肯定有一个好游戏。而且它并不超级贵，你知道，
find, especially if we pick it up like on a steam cell or something else. And the amount of content is, is, you know, literally crazy. And so it's just like one of these stories of like, you know, launching to such, you know, negative reviews, recovering and just turning into like, if you ignore all of that and like just released as a game today, you're like, this is crazy. It's amazing. And, you know, they did it without ever really charging for it.
去寻找，特别是如果我们像在Steam促销或其他地方买到它。内容量，你知道，简直是疯狂。所以这只是这些故事之一，你知道，发布时获得如此负面的评价，恢复并变成，如果你忽略所有这些，就像今天发布的游戏一样，你会说，这太疯狂了。太棒了。而且，你知道，他们做到了，却从未真正收费。
What do you do in this game? So, like, you, like, who are the enemies? What's the progression like? So, I mean, there are enemies, right? So there are ships that will show up and try to destroy settlements or you. You can kind of, like, just run away pretty easily avoid them. And it's kind of like a crafting. an economy thing. So you are collecting resources, which can vary by planet, you know,
你在游戏中做什么？所以，像，你，像，谁是敌人？进度是什么样的？所以，我的意思是，有敌人，对吧？所以会有飞船出现并试图摧毁定居点或你。你可以，像，很容易地跑掉，避开它们。这有点像一个制作，经济的东西。所以你在收集资源，这可能因星球而异，你知道，
or a thing that you need to, you know, like repair your starship to start out with. But then to sell, to trade, you can travel from one planet system to another to, you know, buy goods in one and sell in another and make money to buy bigger ships that you come across. Now there's even content where you can have like a, you know, like a capital ship that can have, it has a hanger and you can like have multiple ships. People can join. your fleet and you can fly, you know, to further away places altogether, then they can go off on missions and earn money. And so the, there isn't like a, I know, it's like a slow game in that way. Like, you're not pushed to say like, oh, you got to hurry up like they're attacking or like,
或者你需要的东西，你知道，像修理你的星际飞船来开始。但随后去出售，去交易，你可以从一个星球系统旅行到另一个，去，你知道，在一个地方买商品，在另一个地方卖，赚钱买你遇到的更大的飞船。现在甚至有内容，你可以拥有一个，你知道，像一个主力舰，它有一个机库，你可以像拥有多艘飞船。人们可以加入你的舰队，你们可以一起飞，你知道，去更远的地方，然后他们可以去执行任务并赚钱。所以，没有一个，我知道，它在某种程度上是一个慢节奏的游戏。像，你不会被催促说，哦，你得快点，像他们正在攻击，或者，
they're increasing in strength and they're going to wipe you out. I don't really find that to be a thing. On certain planets, you need to collect resources that are protected by, you know, robots. And if you collect them and the robot sees you, it'll come after you. Um, you can destroy them for resources. you can just kind of run away. So I would say in that way, it's a bit of like a, it's not casual and that is really complex, but it's not a high risk,
他们正在增加力量，他们会消灭你。我并不觉得那是真的。在某些星球上，你需要收集受机器人保护的资源。如果你收集它们，机器人看到你，它就会追你。嗯，你可以为了资源摧毁它们。你可以只是跑掉。所以我会说在那种方式上，它有点像，它不是休闲的，而且非常复杂，但它不是一个高风险的，
you know, Twitch game where, you know, it's expected to really go out of it. It's much more in the vague way, like in the style of something like Minecraft or Terraria, where, you know, like there are dangers. They're pretty easy to avoid. But you can go do things that are more dangerous if you want. But there's also like a wealth of things to do,
你知道，Twitch游戏，你知道，期望真正去玩。它更像《我的世界》或《泰拉瑞亚》那种风格，你知道，像有危险。它们很容易避开。但如果你想，你可以去做更危险的事情。但也有大量的事情可以做，
base building that, you know, you can choose to engage. engage with in your own way. Is there, is there a boss, kind of like the, the nether dragon or the end dragon in Minecraft? I think they're like are,
基地建设，你知道，你可以选择以自己的方式参与。有，有boss吗，有点像《我的世界》里的末影龙？我想有，
I don't know if there's like a specific end game, although I've never pushed for it. So I don't actually know. But certainly as part of like some of the DLCs, there are like mission arcs that to go on that you can complete, you know, those missions. And some of those missions have,
我不知道是否有特定的结局游戏，虽然我从未追求过。所以我实际上不知道。但当然，作为一些DLC的一部分，有一些任务线可以去完成，你知道，那些任务。其中一些任务有，
it has like the equivalent of kind of like raids at the end that, you know, you fight stuff and you, you know, want to be powerful to take on. but no, I don't think there's like a true conclusion to the game. Got it. Makes sense.
它有像最后那种突袭的东西，你知道，你战斗，你，你知道，想要变得强大去挑战。但没有，我不认为游戏有一个真正的结论。明白了。有道理。
Cool. All right. My tool of this show is paperlib. So if you go and download a research paper today, you will go to probably the site called Archive.org, which has a ton of research papers. And when you download it, you're going to get basically the Archive, which is some gibberish.pdf.
酷。好的。我的本期工具是Paperlib。所以如果你今天去下载一篇研究论文，你可能会去一个叫Archive.org的网站，那里有大量的研究论文。当你下载它时，你基本上会得到Archive，也就是一些乱码.pdf。
And then, which is, you know, when you open it, you'll see the title and all the content. But if you do this enough times, you will fill up your downloads folder with like gibberish.pdf files. And it becomes very difficult to sort of sort through that and know what's going on. So what Paperlib does is it, you know,
然后，你知道，当你打开它时，你会看到标题和所有内容。但如果你这样做足够多次，你的下载文件夹就会塞满像乱码.pdf这样的文件。要整理这些文件并知道发生了什么变得非常困难。所以Paperlib所做的是，它，你知道，
adds a bunch of metadata and it renames the file to the title and then gives you this nice kind of searchable UI. Now here's where it's really cool. Paperlib will let you pick any directory to run in. So to put your to put your files in. And whatever files you put in that directory, it'll rename them, et cetera, et cetera. So I pointed Paperlib to a Google Drive folder. And I said, yeah, use this for your database. And so now on this Google Drive folder, I have all these research papers that have really legible titles.
添加了一堆元数据，并将文件重命名为标题，然后给你这个不错的可搜索界面。现在这里是它真正酷的地方。Paperlib会让你选择任何目录来运行。所以把你的文件放进去。无论你把什么文件放进那个目录，它都会重命名它们，等等等等。所以我把Paperlib指向了一个Google Drive文件夹。我说，是的，用这个作为你的数据库。所以现在在这个Google Drive文件夹上，我有所有这些研究论文，它们有非常清晰的标题。
And so when I use my Nxte paper 14, I point it to my Google Drive folder. And so now it's super neat and organized. That is cool. And it, so does it organize them like into subfolders? like some sort of categorization or mostly just handles like the cleanup of the renaming and stuff. It mostly handles the renaming. Let me check in preferences here.
所以当我使用我的Nxte paper 14时，我把它指向我的Google Drive文件夹。所以现在它超级整洁和有序。太酷了。而且，它会把它们整理成子文件夹吗？像某种分类，还是主要只是处理重命名之类的清理工作？它主要处理重命名。让我检查一下这里的偏好设置。
Because I can't honestly say I've had the problem you're describing. Like it sounds cool. But like I don't have so many research papers that like the name is the problem. Yeah, you can make your own. It looks like you can make your own folders and filters. But it won't do that automatically. But yeah, you can make folders, put papers, you know, group them up by category. You know, is this reinforcement learning? Is this LLMs, et cetera? And, and all that will be reflected on your phone or your tablet or whatever device you're using.
因为我不能诚实地说我遇到过你描述的问题。像，它听起来很酷。但像我没有那么多研究论文，以至于名字是个问题。是的，你可以制作自己的文件夹和过滤器。但它不会自动那样做。但是的，你可以制作文件夹，放入论文，你知道，按类别对它们进行分组。你知道，这是强化学习吗？这是LLM吗，等等。而且，所有这些都会反映在你的手机或平板电脑或你使用的任何设备上。
That's cool. I did something a little similar. I had a bunch of, like, ebooks, like various, you know, PDF, ePubs. And so I attempted to do something similar. It wasn't perfect with one of the, you know, AI tools with computer use, like, pointed at the folder and be like, can you please? like sort, organized, like, D-Dube, like, just kind of, you know, do your best.
太酷了。我做了一些类似的事情。我有一堆，像，电子书，像各种，你知道，PDF，ePub。所以我尝试做类似的事情。它并不完美，用其中一个，你知道，带有计算机使用的AI工具，像，指向文件夹并说，你能请吗？像，排序，整理，像，D-Dube，像，只是，你知道，尽力而为。
And I will say it's getting there. One day it's going to be amazing. But it took it from basically like a flat folder with just the names of the books. Dot random thing and like, you know, made subfolders fiction and hobbies and cookbooks or, you know, whatever. And then, you know, was able to shuffle stuff around.
我会说它正在实现。有一天它会很棒。但它基本上把它从一个只有书名的扁平文件夹变成了。随机的东西，像，你知道，制作了子文件夹，小说、爱好和食谱，或者，你知道，随便什么。然后，你知道，能够把东西洗牌。
Yay. I was low risk. I would be really careful doing it with important documents because it definitely like tried to rename some stuff that was like not. And if you have like Unicode characters in the title, it'll like, you know, didn't handle it well. Like there was a bunch of glitches, but you can definitely see where it's going to start to be a lot of the organization. I have this pet people where like, not pet people.
耶。我风险很低。处理重要文档时我会非常小心，因为它确实像试图重命名一些不是的东西。如果你在标题中有Unicode字符，它会像，你知道，处理得不好。像，有一堆故障，但你绝对可以看到它将开始成为很多组织工作的地方。我有这个宠物人，像，不是宠物人。
I have this thing where I don't like deleting pictures. It just is like, you don't know, like I just keep them all. And one day my hope is that like the tools get better to where like it'll be able to surf it. And it is getting there. Like you can now search for things that are very, what did I search for the other day? It was something that was like not even obvious. And it was like, yeah, found me pictures, right? You used to need to be like really clear,
我有这个习惯，我不喜欢删除照片。它只是像，你不知道，像我只是把它们都留着。有一天我的希望是，像工具变得更好，以至于像它能够冲浪。而且它正在实现。像你现在可以搜索非常，我前几天搜索了什么？那是像甚至不明显的东西。而且它就像，是的，找到了我的照片，对吧？你过去需要像非常清楚，
but now you can say like, I want pictures of dogs, you know, and it'll like show you all the pictures you've taken of dogs and, you know, places. And so I think we're getting closer to where the organization cognitive load can be reduced. And that feels like low hanging fruit. Yeah, that makes sense. But this is a great tip for I'm sure there are a class of people, just like you Jason, who have many, many, many, many doc.
但现在你可以说像，我想要狗的照片，你知道，它会像显示你拍的所有狗的照片，以及，你知道，地点。所以我认为我们越来越接近组织认知负荷可以减少的地方。这感觉像是低垂的果实。是的，这很有道理。但这对于我确信有一类人来说是一个很好的提示，就像你杰森，有很多很多很多很多文档。
It says here, like conference papers. I've never gotten a trunch of conference papers. So maybe one day that will happen to me and I will remember this. Yeah, exactly. Yeah, I mean, it's, yeah, I've just accumulated an insane amount. I mean, I read probably five to ten research papers a week. And after decades of that kind of adds up. If you replace week with year and skim for read, same.
这里说，像会议论文。我从来没有得到过一堆会议论文。所以也许有一天那会发生在我身上，我会记住这一点。是的，完全正确。是的，我的意思是，是的，我只是积累了疯狂的数量。我的意思是，我每周读大概五到十篇研究论文。经过几十年的积累，这加起来不少。如果你把周换成年，把读换成略读，一样。
But mostly look at the pretty pictures. I look at the pictures of a few, you know, research papers every so often. You're like, the graph is not colored. I'm not interested. Black and white. I'd be like, I need to explain it like I'm five. Nope. I need to explain it like I'm two.
但主要是看漂亮的图片。我每隔一段时间看几篇研究论文的图片。你会说，图表没有颜色。我不感兴趣。黑白的。我会说，我需要像五岁小孩一样解释它。不。我需要像两岁小孩一样解释它。
Okay, can you draw it with crayons? I'm still not getting it. Oh, man. Okay. I will hopefully help you get world models. That's our time. Yes, that's what I was going to say. I was going to make the same same way.
好的，你能用蜡笔画出来吗？我还是没听懂。哦，天哪。好的。我希望会帮你得到世界模型。这就是我们的时间。是的，这就是我要说的。我要做同样同样的方式。
Oh, no. It's good. All right. Go ahead. All right. Take it away, Jason. Yeah, we're all thrown off after the adrenochrome comment. So this is why if you're using chapters to go straight to the topic, you need to go back and watch the rest of the list. People are going to be like, what?
哦，不。很好。好的。继续。好的，拿走它，杰森。是的，在肾上腺素评论之后我们都被搞乱了。所以这就是为什么如果你使用章节直接跳到主题，你需要回去看列表的其余部分。人们会像，什么？
World models. All right. So, Patrick, tell me, like, what, this is actually your idea. What inspired you? to want to do a show on world models. Like, how did this come up? Jan Lacoon ragging on meta for not letting him do world models and kicking them out and having to get a billion dollar European startup
世界模型。好的。所以，帕特里克，告诉我，像，什么，这实际上是你的主意。什么启发了你？想要做一个关于世界模型的节目。像，这是怎么出现的？杨立昆（Jan Lacoon）因为Meta不让他做世界模型而对他大发雷霆，把他们踢出去，不得不获得十亿美元的欧洲初创公司，
all in its own. I mean, just to be honest, that was what? That was like, I heard world models and I was like, all right, I did do a little bit of looking after, but that, that's the genesis. Wait, so Jan kind of is ripping on his former employer a little bit. Someone's going to come out. I'm so sorry. What are you supposed to, like, say allegedly or something?
完全靠自己。我的意思是，说实话，那是？那是像，我听到了世界模型，我就像，好的，我确实做了一点点调查，但那，那是起源。等等，所以杨有点在撕他的前雇主。有人要出来了。我很抱歉。你应该，像，说据称或其他什么吗？
I don't know. I'm trying to suggest insinuate that yawn has low impulse control. Is that what we're doing here, Patrick? I don't know that much about him. I just know that I saw it come across tech news like 20 times. And so I was like, okay, there's something he's doing, I think in France and having a startup. And after that I did watch, you know, some videos. So I learned a little bit more.
我不知道。我试图暗示杨的冲动控制力很低。这就是我们在这里做的吗，帕特里克？我对他了解不多。我只知道我看到它在科技新闻上出现了20次。所以我当时想，好的，他在做某事，我想在法国，有一个初创公司。在那之后我确实看了，你知道，一些视频。所以我学到了一点点。
But that was where like I first started seeing this as like a thing. Yeah. So you're basically right on all accounts, especially the low impulse. Oh, no. No, I'm just kidding. So, okay, so, yeah, I think role models, super important. You know, I think that, okay, well, let me address the meta thing really quick. So, you know, really quick.
但那就是我第一次开始把它视为一件事的地方。是的。所以你基本上在所有方面都是对的，特别是低冲动。哦，不。不，我开玩笑的。所以，好的，所以，是的，我认为角色模型，超级重要。你知道，我认为，好的，好吧，让我快速解决Meta的事情。所以，你知道，快速。
So Zuck needs to catch up on LLMs, right? So for whatever reason, you know, LLMs were invented after I left meta, so I can't be to blame for this. But, you know, for whatever reason, people at meta, like, researchers, you know, people in meta-a-I didn't really double triple down on LLMs, even though, like, it was pretty clear that that was huge. So, so now Zuck has to play catch-up. And, you know, he can't be, like, distracted by, like, real long-term visionary stuff, you know, while you're, like, three to five years behind other companies, right? So totally makes sense. Makes sense for Yon to do his own thing too. I mean, it makes sense across the board.
所以扎克需要赶上LLM，对吧？所以无论什么原因，你知道，LLM是在我离开Meta之后发明的，所以我不能为此负责。但是，你知道，无论什么原因，Meta的人，像，研究人员，你知道，Meta-AI的人并没有真正加倍三倍地投入LLM，即使，像，很明显那是巨大的。所以，所以现在扎克必须赶上。而且，你知道，他不能，像，被，像，真正的长期愿景的东西分心，你知道，当你，像，落后其他公司三到五年时，对吧？所以完全有道理。杨去做他自己的事情也有道理。我的意思是，这在各方面都有道理。
Hopefully there isn't any bad blood there from anyone. But, okay, so that's the deal with that. So we'll talk about world models. To talk about world models, we have to talk about making decisions with AI. And we've talked about this before on the show, but I'll do a quick recap. So regular AI, you know, hot dog, not hot dog. Oh, I love it. Let's go. You draw a bounding box around the hot dog as a human.
希望那里没有任何坏血。但是，好的，这就是那件事的处理方式。所以我们将谈论世界模型。要谈论世界模型，我们必须谈论用AI做决定。我们之前在节目中谈过这个，但我会做一个快速回顾。所以常规AI，你知道，热狗，不是热狗。哦，我喜欢它。我们走吧。你作为人类在热狗周围画一个边界框。
You know, you personally draw a bounding box or you hire contractors to do this. And you call that ground truth. You're like, okay, if a human did it, it must be right. Maybe use an ensemble of people, you know, on the same bounding box just to really make sure. But now you have what's called ground truth. You know, I drew a picture. I drew a box around the hot dog or around the car or whatever it is. and I know it's there.
你知道，你亲自画一个边界框或者你雇佣承包商来做这个。你称之为地面实况（ground truth）。你就像，好的，如果人类做了，那一定是对的。也许使用一群人，你知道，在同一个边界框上，只是为了真正确定。但现在你有了所谓的地面实况。你知道，我画了一张图。我在热狗周围或汽车周围或任何东西周围画了一个框，我知道它在那里。
So then you ask the AI, hey, is there a car in this picture? And if it says no, or if it draws the box in a wrong spot or something, you correct it, right? And that's relatively straightforward from that perspective. Now, the problem is,
所以然后你问AI，嘿，这张图里有车吗？如果它说没有，或者如果它把框画在错误的地方或其他什么，你纠正它，对吧？从那个角度来看，这相对直接。现在，问题是，
oh, actually one more piece of this, is then you rely on interpolation, right? Clearly, you don't have every picture of every situation you'll ever see in the universe, but you get enough pictures of enough cars and you draw enough bounding boxes that then you can interpolate. And when you see a car in a situation you've never seen before, you should still be able to find it. Okay. So for decision making, right, you could argue, why don't we do the same thing? So let's take all the best stock picks or all the best
哦，实际上这还有一部分，就是然后你依赖插值（interpolation），对吧？显然，你没有宇宙中你将看到的每种情况的每张图片，但你得到了足够多汽车的图片，你画了足够多的边界框，然后你就可以插值。当你看到一个你从未见过的场景中的汽车时，你应该仍然能够找到它。好的。所以对于决策，对吧，你可以争论，为什么我们不做同样的事情？所以让我们拿走所有最好的股票选择或所有最好的，
grand master chess moves and train a model to say, hey, when you see this chess board, do this chess move, when you see this situation in the stock market, buy this stock, and then hope that we get the same interpolation. In practice, it doesn't work. So when you interpolate and you try to take those things you memorize and apply them to other chess boards or other stock situations, they just don't interpolate that well. So you can still do this. It's called imitation learning, and it's still a very good approach to get started. But you, unlike supervised learning where that's all you do, and in the end, you're done,
特级大师国际象棋走法，并训练一个模型说，嘿，当你看到这个棋盘时，做这个棋子移动，当你看到股市中的这种情况时，买这只股票，然后希望我们得到同样的插值。在实践中，它不起作用。所以当你插值并试图把你记住的那些东西应用到其他棋盘或其他股票情况时，它们就是插值不好。所以你仍然可以这样做。这叫模仿学习（imitation learning），它仍然是一个很好的入门方法。但你，不像监督学习那样，那是你所做的全部，最后，你就完成了，
this will not get you a good solution. So what you have to do is get better without any human in the loop. And the question is, how do you do that? Well, you make a decision and you execute this decision kind of out there in the real world. And then you measure whether that decision was good or bad, right? If it was good, then you adjust your model to do that decision more often, you know, at the expense of alternatives. And if it was bad, you do the opposite.
这不会给你带来好的解决方案。所以你必须做的是在没有人工干预的情况下变得更好。问题是，你该怎么做呢？嗯，你做出一个决定，然后在现实世界中执行这个决定。然后你衡量这个决定是好是坏，对吧？如果是好的，你就调整你的模型，以牺牲其他选择为代价，更频繁地做出这个决定。如果是坏的，你就反其道而行之。
it. You make that decision less often, which, you know, kind of implicitly causes the other decisions to become other options to become more likely, right? So, so now the question is, what is good and bad? Like, I'll give you an example. Let's say you have two choices. One choice gives you a dollar and the other choice gives you a thousand dollars. Well, let's say you take the first choice and you get a dollar. You're like, oh, that's good. I got a dollar. I don't even need to try the second choice, right? So you miss out on the $1,000, right? So it turns out in that example I gave, the $1 decision is actually bad even though you got a dollar. And so to solve this, you need what's called a baseline. So a baseline says, you know, given my policy, given, you know, my,
你减少做出该决定的频率，这在某种程度上隐含地导致其他决定或选项变得更有可能，对吧？那么现在的问题是，什么是好，什么是坏？我给你举个例子。假设你有两个选择。一个选择给你一美元，另一个选择给你一千美元。假设你选择了第一个，得到了一美元。你会觉得，哦，那很好。我得到了一美元。我甚至不需要尝试第二个选择，对吧？所以你错过了那一千美元，对吧？事实证明，在我给出的那个例子中，那一美元的决定实际上是糟糕的，即使你确实得到了一美元。为了解决这个问题，你需要所谓的基准（baseline）。基准就是说，根据我的策略，我期望得到什么？起初，你的策略只是随机的，因为你什么都不知道，对吧？所以基准，假设你有一个完美的基准，它会说，哦，我期望你得到500美元，因为那是1和1000的平均值，或者550美分之类的，对吧？所以你采取行动，得到了一美元，然后你就知道你搞砸了。就像是，哦，我的基准说平均我应该得到500，但我只得到了1。所以那是一个糟糕的举动。如果你有一个完美的基准，并且你做了足够多次，你最终会每次都选择那一千美元，对吧？同样，如果你有一个完美的策略，那么你就可以得到一个基准。
you know, my strategy, what do I expect to get? And so in the beginning, you're strategy is just random because you don't know anything, right? And so the baseline, let's say you had a perfect baseline, it would say, oh, I expect you to get 500 bucks because that's, you know, the average of one in a thousand or 550 cents or something, right? So you take an action, you get a dollar, then you know you messed up. It's like, oh, my baseline said on average, I should be getting 500 and I only got one. So that was a bad move. And if you had a perfect baseline and you did this enough times, you would eventually pick the $1,000 every time, right? Similarly, if you had a perfect policy, then you could get a baseline.
（注：此段落原文与132段落末尾及133段落开头有重叠，按要求逐行翻译）
So if I had a policy that, you know, always chose the $1,000 every time, then when I get to that decision, my baseline would say, oh, I expect you to get $1,000. I expect you to not even bother with the $1 action. So, you know, a perfect policy requires a perfect baseline. A baseline is dependent on a policy. And so in hints, you see the problem. You have two things that are dependent on each other. And so you end up doing what we call in the math world a relaxation approach, which is a fancy way of saying, if you have two things that depend on each other, you. And so you end up doing, other, you look at one of them and optimize it, assuming the other one is perfect. And then you switch.
所以如果我有一个策略，总是每次都选择那一千美元，那么当我做出那个决定时，我的基准会说，哦，我期望你得到一千美元。我期望你甚至不要去理会那一美元的行动。所以，一个完美的策略需要一个完美的基准。基准依赖于策略。因此，你看到了问题所在。你有两件事是相互依赖的。所以你最终会做我们在数学界所说的松弛法（relaxation approach），这是一种花哨的说法，意思是如果你有两件事相互依赖，你最终会做的是，你观察其中一个并优化它，假设另一个是完美的。然后你切换。
You go to the second one and assuming the first one is perfect, you optimize the second one, and you keep going back and forth. Like this is what K-means clustering does, right? So that at a high level is how you make decisions with AI. And you could do reinforcement learning, evolutionary strategies, no matter what you do, if you're making decisions with AI, it's going to be that. So any questions about that kind of foundational part? No, so I guess you're kind of putting on this realization step is you're like trying to explore to understand what's possible and help like inform where the line between sort of better and less good is.
你转向第二个，假设第一个是完美的，你优化第二个，然后你不断地来回切换。就像K-means聚类所做的那样，对吧？所以从高层来看，这就是你如何用人工智能做决定。你可以做强化学习、进化策略，无论你做什么，如果你是用人工智能做决定，它都会是这样。那么关于这个基础部分有什么问题吗？没有，所以我猜你是在进行这个实现步骤，你是想通过探索来理解什么是可能的，并帮助确定“更好”和“没那么好”之间的界限在哪里。
Yep, that's right. You're trying to find, you're trying to find a baseline. and then you're also trying to update the policy. Whenever you update the policy, that changes the baseline. So, you know, our baseline started at $500 because we were picking the $1 half the time. But as our policy gets better, our baseline also goes up. And so, you know, in this fictitious example where you have two decisions, one gives you a dollar, the other gives you $1,000, your baseline will climb to a thousand dollars as your policy climbs towards always picking a thousand dollar action but they're going to how do you how do you oh sorry and so like in that
是的，没错。你是在试图找到一个基准，然后你也在试图更新策略。每当你更新策略时，基准就会改变。所以，我们的基准从500美元开始，因为我们有一半时间在选那一美元。但随着我们的策略变得更好，我们的基准也会上升。所以，在这个虚构的例子中，你有两个决定，一个给你一美元，另一个给你一千美元，你的基准会攀升到一千美元，随着你的策略向总是选择一千美元的行动靠拢，但它们会……你怎么……哦，抱歉，所以就像在那种
case it was dollars well you used chess earlier but like chess doesn't have a obvious numerical expression for a baseline right like you could have how much material you're up or down but that's like a very crude it doesn't sort of express to you if you're improving your position or worsening your, you know, opportunities to win. Yep. So, so chess is a multi-step problem, right? Where the only thing that matters in chess is the last step that wins the game. So, so the last step that wins the game, you know, gives that, that agent a score of one and the other agent of score of negative one. And so what you have to do then is propagate through time so that now your baseline is including the like expected future reward.
情况下是美元，嗯，你之前用了国际象棋，但国际象棋没有明显的基准数值表达，对吧？就像你可以拥有多少棋子优势，但这非常粗糙，它并不能表达你是在改善你的位置还是在恶化你获胜的机会。是的。所以，国际象棋是一个多步骤的问题，对吧？在国际象棋中唯一重要的是最后一步，即赢得比赛的那一步。所以，赢得比赛的最后一步给那个智能体一个1的分数，给另一个智能体一个负1的分数。所以你必须做的是在时间上进行传播，这样你的基准现在就包含了预期的未来奖励。
Okay. So that's like sort of what they end of doing, AlphaGo or whatever, trying to say like a given position, how likely is it to win? But, but it's sort of like trying to roll forward across all the possibilities. Yeah, exactly. And it is dependent on the policy.
好的。所以这有点像AlphaGo或其他东西最终做的事情，试图说给定一个位置，获胜的可能性有多大？但这有点像试图在所有可能性中向前推进。是的，完全正确。而且它确实依赖于策略。
Like if I happen to play the same move as AlphaGo on my first move, my baseline is totally different because I suck. Right. So like alpha goes baseline If they're playing a world champion Might be 0.6. They expect 60% chance that they're going to win My baseline against the same world champion
如果我在第一步碰巧走了和AlphaGo一样的棋，我的基准完全不同，因为我很烂。对吧。所以AlphaGo的基准，如果他们是在和世界冠军对弈，可能是0.6。他们期望有60%的获胜机会。而我对阵同一个世界冠军的基准
So the same situation is going to be zero But I guess it makes sense as well Because the positions from which you could win from Are probably different. Like Alva Go could be in a much more complicated situation Potentially and still like win if it's possible versus if you get into a complex situation Your chance for mistake is much higher
所以同样的情况会是零。但我猜这也说得通，因为你可以获胜的位置可能不同。就像AlphaGo可能处于一个复杂得多的情况，如果可能的话仍然能赢，而如果你陷入一个复杂的情况，你犯错的机会要高得多。
So it might be better to me. move to a theoretically heart, like theoretically less good position, but it's simpler, and so your chance of making the right decisions is better. Right. Yeah, but even independent to that, you know, if I'm, let's say, tracking AlphaGo, my
所以对我来说，移动到一个理论上更难、理论上没那么好的位置可能会更好，但它更简单，所以你做出正确决定的机会更好。对吧。是的，但即使独立于此，你知道，如果我是在追踪AlphaGo，我的
baseline's going to be low because I'm expected to be making mistakes in the future. Okay. You know, and then eventually at some point, if I just somehow coincidentally matched AlphaGo performance, and at the very, very end, I would get a baseline of one, right before I win.
基准会很低，因为我预计未来会犯错。好的。你知道，然后最终在某个时刻，如果我只是碰巧匹配了AlphaGo的表现，在最后，我会在获胜前得到一个为1的基准，对吧。
But my baseline would generally be low because they just know that, you know, Jason makes tons of mistakes. And so it's going to happen eventually. This is why the baseline is downstream from the policy. Got it. So,
但我的基准通常会很低，因为他们只是知道Jason会犯很多错误。所以这最终会发生。这就是为什么基准是策略的下游。明白了。所以，
okay, so what I just talked about, you know, you have a policy which says, hey, here's the probability of taking these different actions. and at some point I'll actually take an action, and then if that action comes back, let's say, you know, better than I expected, then, you know, my propensity for that action goes up, my baseline for that action goes up,
好的，所以我刚才谈到的，你有一个策略，它说，嘿，这是采取这些不同行动的概率。在某个时刻，我实际上会采取一个行动，然后如果那个行动的结果，比方说，比我预期的要好，那么我对那个行动的倾向就会上升，我对那个行动的基准也会上升，
et cetera, et cetera. But you have to actually take the action to find that out. And so let's just take a self-driving car example. If you don't know that driving off a cliff is bad, well then you have to try it out. So the question, how do we fix that? And you know, you could do this through engineering, right? You could say something like if we're too close to the curb, you know,
等等，等等。但你必须真正采取行动才能发现这一点。让我们以自动驾驶汽车为例。如果你不知道开车冲下悬崖是不好的，那么你就必须尝试一下。所以问题是，我们如何解决这个问题？你可以通过工程手段来做到这一点，对吧？你可以说，如果我们离路缘太近，有一些规则会启动，我们会让车慢下来。这超出了本集的范围，对吧？我的意思是，这变成了另一个问题，对吧？但如果你只是想使用机器学习，那么你就必须使用模拟器，对吧？你不会只是把车扔下每一个悬崖，对吧？所以在模拟器中，你把大量的车扔下悬崖，它就会学到，嘿，我把车扔下悬崖的那个行动，与保持生存的基准相比，真的很糟糕。所以，在模拟中扔了这么多车之后，它就会学会不那样做，对吧？所以，对。
there's some rule that kicks in and we slow the car down. That's outside of the scope of this episode, right? I mean, that becomes a different problem, right? But if you just want to use machine learning, then you have to use a simulator, right? You're not going to be just throwing cars off every cliff, right? So in the simulator, you throw tons of cars off cliffs, and it learns that, hey, you know, the action where I throw the car off the cliff is really, really bad compared to the baseline of staying alive. And so, you know, after throwing so many cars off cliffs in Sim, it'll learn not to do that, right? So, right.
（注：此段落原文与145段落末尾有重叠，按要求逐行翻译）
So to do that, you have to build this really complicated simulator, right? And you have what's called like a sim to real problem where the simulator never fully matches the real world. You know, the sky looks different. The ground looks slightly different. There aren't drunk drivers in the simulator. You know, maybe the road isn't bent, like, you know, isn't rolled at all in the simulator, right? there's all these things that are not in the simulator but are in the real world, and you kind of are constantly fighting that, right?
所以要做到这一点，你必须建立这个非常复杂的模拟器，对吧？而且你有所谓的“从模拟到现实”（sim to real）的问题，即模拟器永远无法完全匹配现实世界。你知道，天空看起来不同。地面看起来略有不同。模拟器里没有酒驾司机。你知道，也许道路在模拟器里根本没有弯曲，对吧？有所有这些东西在模拟器里没有，但在现实世界里有，你一直在与此抗争，对吧？
So what if instead of trying to build a simulator, you know, using some sim engine, and then sort of shoehorning that into your problem, what if you created a simulator as part of solving the problem? And so this is what model-based decision-making or model-based reinforcement learning is doing. It's saying, hey, I'm going to build my own simulator while I'm trying to drive the car. And so there's a bunch of criteria of what makes a good simulator,
那么，如果不是试图建立一个模拟器，使用某种模拟引擎，然后将其强行塞进你的问题中，如果你在解决问题的过程中创建一个模拟器会怎样？这就是基于模型的决策或基于模型的强化学习所做的事情。它是在说，嘿，我要在开车的同时建立我自己的模拟器。所以有很多关于什么构成一个好模拟器的标准，
but it's not a simulator that you or I can see in the same way as we can't see what an LLM is doing. We can only see the algorithm. Got it. Right. So it's some big neural net mess, right? But it's inside of that mess is a simulator that can predict the future given, you know, you turn the steering wheel this way. This is what the future looks like in this simulated space.
但它不是你或我能看到的模拟器，就像我们看不到LLM在做什么一样。我们只能看到算法。明白了。对。所以它是一团巨大的神经网络混乱，对吧？但在那团混乱中是一个模拟器，它可以在你这样转动方向盘时预测未来。这就是在这个模拟空间中未来看起来的样子。
So it takes like a state and the decision and predicts the new state. Exactly. Yeah, exactly. Now, the original state might be like a whole bunch of cameras, right? And so predicting cameras means you have to draw a bunch of images of the future, right? Which can be really difficult. Like you have to handle the movement of the clouds, all this stuff, right? So what people do is they'll create what's called a latent state, which is where they've collapsed all these camera images into some like blob,
所以它需要一个状态和决定，并预测新状态。完全正确。是的，完全正确。现在，原始状态可能是一堆摄像头，对吧？所以预测摄像头意味着你必须画出一堆未来的图像，对吧？这可能非常困难。你必须处理云的移动，所有这些东西，对吧？所以人们所做的是创建一个所谓的潜在状态（latent state），即他们将所有这些摄像头图像压缩成某种“斑点”（blob），
where the blob hopefully doesn't have clouds in it because they're not necessary to drive a car. Like the blob hopefully just has important stuff in it. Then you say, okay, given this blob and I press the accelerator button, what's the next blob? This is why Jan Lecun was saying in that thing I was referencing that if you were trying to do self-driving and you're like predicting the next thing, you're just going to end up spending all your tokens trying to predict tree leaves. Yeah. This is the same point. It's like you're saying leaves look like this in a video frame and in the next video frame they look not. not in the same position because of wind,
其中这个斑点希望没有云在里面，因为它们对驾驶汽车不是必需的。这个斑点希望只包含重要的东西。然后你说，好的，给定这个斑点，我按下加速器按钮，下一个斑点是什么？这就是为什么Yann LeCun在那个我引用的东西里说，如果你试图做自动驾驶，并且你在预测下一件事，你最终只会把所有的token都花在预测树叶上。是的。这是同样的观点。就像你是说在视频帧中叶子看起来是这样的，而在下一帧中它们看起来不是。不是在同一个位置，因为风，
but really that's just noise. It's irrelevant. Right, right. So the question is, how do I go from the state to that blob? And the answer is, a good blob is one that when I apply an action,
但实际上那只是噪音。它是无关紧要的。对，对。所以问题是，我如何从状态变成那个斑点？答案是，一个好的斑点是当我应用一个行动时，
I get another blob. So think of it this way. Like, you can, and this is called encoding. You can encode the state into the blob, take an action, and now you get the future blob, right? But you can also take the same action in the real world and then encode the feature and you should get the same blob.
我得到另一个斑点。所以这样想。你可以，这被称为编码（encoding）。你可以将状态编码成斑点，采取行动，现在你得到了未来的斑点，对吧？但你也可以在现实世界中采取同样的行动，然后编码特征，你应该得到同样的斑点。
See what I'm saying? Mm-hmm. Now, there is a catch, which is what if my encoder, it just makes a blob of all zeros. So I have a blob that's all zeros. And then every action just takes the zero blob and makes another zero blob. Winning. Yeah. Well, now my future, when I encode the future, I get a zero blob, and it's perfect, right?
明白我的意思吗？嗯。现在，有一个陷阱，那就是如果我的编码器只是制造了一个全零的斑点怎么办？所以我有一个全零的斑点。然后每一个行动都只是取零斑点并制造另一个零斑点。赢了。是的。好吧，现在我的未来，当我编码未来时，我得到了一个零斑点，它是完美的，对吧？
So you have to prevent that. And that's where there's a bunch of techniques. But basically, this is called prior posterior regularization. And there's a bunch of techniques for this, but the gist of it is you have two blobs. You have the blob that you got from encoding and then taking the action. and you have the blob that you got from taking the action and then encoding. And those two blobs, you can get the covariance matrix of those two blobs. And the diagonal of the covariance matrix, you want that to be one,
所以你必须防止这种情况。这就是有一堆技术的地方。但基本上，这被称为先验后验正则化（prior posterior regularization）。有很多技术可以做到这一点，但其要点是你有两个斑点。你有从编码然后采取行动得到的斑点，你有从采取行动然后编码得到的斑点。那两个斑点，你可以得到那两个斑点的协方差矩阵。协方差矩阵的对角线，你希望它是1，
and you want the off diagonals to be zero. So in other words, if you do the zero blob, well, then the covariance matrix will collapse because it will be zero to zero every single time. And so you'll have a, the off diagonal elements will be zero, which is good, but the diagonal elements will also collapse to zero, which is bad. And so this regularization punishes that hack from from succeeding. Okay, so that's the way to sort of like keep it from saying, I don't know what to do. So I'll just, you know, basically the equivalent of give-up, I'll just like blur it all out until it turns into just, you know, some base value zero or whatever. Yeah, exactly.
你希望非对角线是0。换句话说，如果你做了零斑点，那么协方差矩阵就会崩溃，因为它每次都是0到0。所以你会有，非对角元素会是0，这很好，但对角元素也会崩溃到0，这很糟糕。所以这种正则化惩罚了那种黑客行为的成功。好的，所以这就是防止它说“我不知道该做什么”的方法。所以我只会，你知道，基本上相当于放弃，我只会把它模糊化，直到它变成只是，你知道，某种基准值0之类的。是的，完全正确。
Okay, so now, let's say I'm in the car. So I'm not training the model anymore. I'm actually in the car. I have this model-based reinforcement or anything already trained, right? Well, now what I can do is I can say, if I was to press the accelerator, what would that next blob look like? like. And I could have some other model that says, given a blob, am I driving off a cliff or not? So if I put those two together, and I can say, oh, if I press the accelerator really hard, I'm going to create a blob that's a, you know, going to die blob. And so I don't want that.
好的，现在，假设我在车里。所以我不再训练模型了。我实际上在车里。我已经训练好了这个基于模型的强化学习，对吧？好吧，现在我可以做的是，我可以说，如果我要按下加速器，下一个斑点会是什么样子？我可以有另一个模型，它说，给定一个斑点，我是在冲下悬崖还是没有？所以如果我把这两者放在一起，我可以说，哦，如果我用力按下加速器，我会制造一个斑点，一个“你要死了”的斑点。所以我不想那样。
So even though my policy says to press the accelerator, when I roll it out, when I actually look at the future, those blobs look pretty bad. So I'm going to go against what the policy says, and I'm actually going to hit the brakes, because I used my model and it said that hitting the gas is bad. But doing that like recurrent, recursive, however you want to say it, like keep taking the state, do the action and keep looping the state over. That's where you're going to get the drift, though, right? Like, that's where it's going to be harder and harder at like longer time horizons to say that the blob is what it is representative. of Yeah, so you can start hallucinating.
所以即使我的策略说要按下加速器，当我把它展开时，当我真正观察未来时，那些斑点看起来很糟糕。所以我将违背策略所说的，我实际上会踩刹车，因为我使用了我的模型，它说踩油门是不好的。但像那样循环、递归，无论你怎么说，就像保持采取状态，做行动并保持循环状态。这就是你会得到漂移（drift）的地方，对吧？就像，在更长的时间跨度上，说这个斑点是有代表性的会越来越难。是的，所以你可能会开始产生幻觉。
You know, you can end up with, as you said, with drift, where you go, what's called going off manifold, but you end up with a blob that isn't real. Like, you'd never see in the real world, and then you're kind of in trouble. That can happen. There are ways to address that. But, oh, the other part of it is you only roll out maybe 16, 32, 64 steps.
你知道，你最终可能会像你说的，出现漂移，你走到了所谓的“离流形”（off manifold），但你最终得到一个不真实的斑点。就像，你在现实世界中永远不会看到，然后你就陷入了麻烦。这可能会发生。有解决这个问题的方法。但是，哦，另一部分是你只展开大约16、32、64步。
So you don't roll out, you know, minutes into the future. You basically say, if I take this action over the next five seconds, am I, do I see a blob where it's a you're going to die blob? And if I don't, then that's good. And you can even do what's called model predictive control where you take, you take an action, it says you're going to die, or maybe you take like 30 different types of actions, and then 15 of them say you're going to die.
所以你不会展开，你知道，几分钟后的未来。你基本上说，如果我在接下来的五秒钟内采取这个行动，我是否，我是否看到一个斑点，它是“你要死了”的斑点？如果我没有，那么那很好。你甚至可以做所谓的模型预测控制（model predictive control），你采取一个行动，它说你会死，或者也许你采取大约30种不同的行动，然后其中15个说你会死。
you pick the other 15 and you use them as a seed to generate some more actions and you kind of like on the fly kind of hill climb towards the best action. And so this smoothens out. You know, with neural nets, there's just so much variance, right? So this smoothens out a lot of that. You know, if your neural net freaks out one out of a hundred times, this is the thing that keeps you from dying in your Tesla that 1% of the time. Any questions about MBRL? No, I mean, I think I, yeah, I think I understand it at least at the five-year-old level you're going. So thank you.
你选择另外15个，并把它们作为种子来生成更多的行动，你有点像在飞行中向最好的行动爬坡。所以这平滑了。你知道，对于神经网络，方差太大了，对吧？所以这平滑了很多。你知道，如果你的神经网络一百次里有一次发疯，这就是防止你在特斯拉里在那1%的时间里死亡的东西。关于MBRL有什么问题吗？没有，我的意思是，我想我，是的，我想我至少在五岁小孩的水平上理解了它。所以谢谢。
I appreciate it. All right. Now, here's where it becomes a world model. Okay. So that wasn't a world model yet. Oh, not a world model yet. Okay. So we talked about, you know, when you're actually physically in the Tesla, it does these rollouts, right?
我很感激。好的。现在，这就是它成为世界模型（world model）的地方。好的。所以那还不是世界模型。哦，还不是世界模型。好的。所以我们谈到了，你知道，当你实际上在特斯拉里时，它会做这些展开，对吧？
and it might not do the action that the policy wants because it rolled it out and it was not good. Right. So the question is, like, can't you at that point use your model to train itself, right? So, like, if my policy says to press the accelerator and it says I'm going to die, you know, Why don't I just fix the policy right then and there? Like, why do I have to be in a real car to do that? Even just during training, I could start with something real, like start with a scene where you're driving on a cliff side,
而且它可能不会做策略想要的行动，因为它展开了它，结果不好。对吧。所以问题是，在那一点上，你不能用你的模型来训练它自己吗？所以，就像，如果我的策略说按下加速器，而它说我会死，你知道，为什么我不就在那时那里修复策略呢？就像，为什么我必须在真正的车里才能做到这一点？即使只是在训练期间，我也可以从真实的东西开始，比如从你在悬崖边开车的一个场景开始，
but then inside the model, do that drive, find things where you fell off the cliff, correct them, and then do all of that inside of the model without having to need an external simulator or driving in the real world or any of that. You're just like hallucinating problems and solutions. And so that's where it becomes a world model. Okay, I see. Yeah, so think of it as kind of like baking that thing that you do in the real car, like baking that, you know, into the model.
但在模型内部，做那个驾驶，找到你掉下悬崖的地方，纠正它们，然后在模型内部完成所有这些，而不需要外部模拟器或在现实世界中驾驶或任何这些。你只是在产生问题和解决方案的幻觉。所以这就是它成为世界模型的地方。好的，我明白了。是的，所以把它想象成有点像把你真车里做的那件事，像烘焙那个，你知道，进模型里。
Okay, all right. And so if you were to take, for example, Dreamer v4, they actually do this thing where they trained a model to play Minecraft. Or not to play Minecraft, maybe specific. They trained a model to understand Minecraft. So they watched like a zillion videos of people playing Minecraft and they trained a model where, again, this is all in blobs. You can't see the game or anything. But just in blobs, they swing a pickax. and then the next blob has presumably like some logs in your inventory or something, right?
好的，好的。所以如果你要举个例子，Dreamer v4，他们实际上做了这件事，他们训练了一个模型来玩Minecraft。或者不是玩Minecraft，也许是特定的。他们训练了一个模型来理解Minecraft。所以他们看了像一亿个视频的人玩Minecraft，他们训练了一个模型，同样，这都是在斑点里。你看不到游戏或任何东西。但只是在斑点里，他们挥动镐。然后下一个斑点大概有，比如你库存里的一些原木之类的，对吧？
And so just based on on looking at people playing Minecraft, they were able to build this model, and then they were able to train just in the model with the goal of get diamonds. And literally without touching a keyboard or being able to play even one frame of Minecraft, they were able to learn an AI that train an AI that could get diamonds 0.6% of the time, which isn't a lot, but it's still pretty amazing. They basically took this thing that had never been able to touch a keyboard, put it in front of Minecraft,
所以仅仅基于看人们玩Minecraft，他们就能够建立这个模型，然后他们能够只在模型中训练，目标是获得钻石。而且字面上没有碰过键盘或甚至不能玩Minecraft的一帧，他们就能够学习一个AI，训练一个AI，可以在0.6%的时间里获得钻石，这虽然不多，但仍然非常惊人。他们基本上拿了这个从未能碰过键盘的东西，把它放在Minecraft面前，
and one out of 200 times it gets diamonds. So all that learning was all done on Blobs. Okay. I think I got it. And Blobs is the what they call like the latent space, whatever. That's right. Okay.
然后200次里有一次它得到了钻石。所以所有的学习都是在斑点上完成的。好的。我想我明白了。而斑点就是他们所说的潜在空间（latent space），什么的。没错。好的。
Okay. Yeah. And then how did they know it got diamonds? Like, presumably they have some decoder for the blob for at least some things. Yeah. So they did all this training on the latent space, right, on the blobs, right? Then they froze the training and then they put the trained model in front of a real Minecraft game. Oh, okay.
好的。是的。然后他们怎么知道它得到了钻石？就像，大概他们对斑点至少有一些解码器。是的。所以他们在潜在空间上做了所有的训练，对吧，在斑点上，对吧？然后他们冻结了训练，然后他们把训练好的模型放在一个真正的Minecraft游戏面前。哦，好的。
Okay. Got it. All right. That makes sense. Yeah. And that's where they got the one out of 200, which is. amazing result. I mean,
好的。明白了。好的。这说得通。是的。这就是他们得到200分之一的地方，这是一个惊人的结果。我的意思是，
now, if you continue training based on, you know, those videos that it created of itself, then it got diamonds almost every time,
现在，如果你继续基于，你知道，它自己创造的那些视频进行训练，那么它几乎每次都能得到钻石，
which we already knew. But the fact that it could just watch other people play, build its own model of how that game works, and then get diamonds one out 200 times. It's pretty amazing.
我们已经知道了。但它能仅仅通过看别人玩，建立自己关于那个游戏如何运作的模型，然后200次里有一次得到钻石。这非常惊人。
And that's the hope that is like, as humans, you're a baby and you watch stuff around you, and even without trying it yourself, you're then able to basically do or perform it very high accuracy on the first time often. Right. But that the models generally can't.
这就是希望，就像，作为人类，你是一个婴儿，你观察周围的东西，即使没有自己尝试，你也能在第一次时通常以非常高的准确度执行或表现它。对。但模型通常不能。
Like today, machine learning isn't really capable of replicating that. Right. Yeah, exactly. Okay. So now there's a big debate around whether you should reconstruct the raw state or not. So the dreamer folks, which is a team out of deep mind, all of their models, even the latest one that came out like six months ago, reconstructs the original. state. So in the case of Minecraft, you know, you have your screenshot of the game and it does all
就像今天，机器学习并没有真正能够复制这一点。对。是的，完全正确。好的。所以现在关于你是否应该重建原始状态有一个大争论。所以Dreamer的人，这是DeepMind的一个团队，他们所有的模型，即使是六个月前出来的那个最新的，也会重建原始状态。所以在Minecraft的情况下，你知道，你有游戏的截图，它做了所有
the things we talked about, but it also outputs the screenshots of the future or the screenshots as it's going. And you can actually see it like go and mine diamonds and it's all kind of fuzzy, right? Because it's, it's all going through this blob space. So it's, you know, a lot of the clouds have been destroyed. I don't say, but like anything that's irrelevant is basically not present. So that's where the blurriness comes from. Exactly, exactly. Clouds are totally destroyed because they're useless, right, to actually playing
我们谈到的事情，但它也输出未来的截图或它进行时的截图。你实际上可以看到它去挖掘钻石，而且这一切都有点模糊，对吧？因为它，它都是通过这个斑点空间。所以它，你知道，很多云已经被摧毁了。我不是说，但就像任何无关紧要的东西基本上都不存在。所以这就是模糊性的来源。完全正确，完全正确。云被完全摧毁了，因为它们是无用的，对吧，对于实际玩
Minecraft. But, but, but yeah, you know, it recreates the state as it goes. You can actually watch it play Minecraft while it's training, you know, in some really weird way. And so, so Dreamers definitely in the camp of, And they have a bunch of arguments for, you know, if you don't, to Yon's, to use Yon's metaphor, you know, if you don't reconstruct the leaves or at least try to, then you're not robust. So in other words, the problem with Yon's argument, and I'm just, I'm not saying he's wrong.
Minecraft。但是，但是，但是是的，你知道，它在进行时重建了状态。你实际上可以在它训练时看着它玩Minecraft，你知道，以某种非常奇怪的方式。所以，所以Dreamer绝对是在那个阵营里，而且他们有一堆论点，你知道，如果你不这样做，用Yann的隐喻，你知道，如果你不重建叶子，或者至少尝试这样做，那么你就不是鲁棒的。所以换句话说，Yann论点的问题，我只是，我不是说他是错的。
I'm just playing devil's advocate. Yeah. Yeah. The problem with Yon's argument is we already know that the leaves are useless for self-driving because we have common sense. But, you know, that was an assumption that we made, right? Like, it's not obvious. It's not like just implicit in the form of a tree and the leaves that those leaves are not important for self-driving. Right. It's only because of other stuff that we know. And so if you're reconstructing the original state, then, you know, you have the potential to use anything.
我只是在唱反调。是的。是的。Yann论点的问题是我们已经知道叶子对于自动驾驶是无用的，因为我们有常识。但是，你知道，那是我们做出的一个假设，对吧？就像，它不是显而易见的。并不是说在树和叶子的形式中隐含着这些叶子对于自动驾驶不重要。对。这只是因为我们知道的其他东西。所以如果你在重建原始状态，那么，你知道，你有潜力使用任何东西。
So put another way, maybe in the beginning of self-driving, you're just trying to do the highway, right? And so if you use Yon-Lacoon's approach, well, then stop signs that you might see when you're looking down from the highway will also get destroyed because you don't need to worry about stop signs when you're on the highway. But as soon as you say, okay, I want this car to drive on city streets, well, now it doesn't have stop signs. And so you have to start all over again. With the dreamer approach, because you're reconstructing the original state, it actually will need to understand stop signs, even though they're useless. And so then when you change your driving domain, you'll be prepared to that. So in the deep mind approach, not only do you regenerate like the Minecraft screen, does the Minecraft screen then be like, is that what goes back into the blob?
所以换句话说，也许在自动驾驶的开始，你只是试图做高速公路，对吧？所以如果你使用Yann LeCun的方法，那么当你从高速公路上往下看时可能会看到的停车标志也会被摧毁，因为当你在高速公路上时你不需要担心停车标志。但一旦你说，好的，我想要这辆车在城市街道上行驶，那么现在它没有停车标志了。所以你必须从头开始。使用Dreamer的方法，因为你在重建原始状态，它实际上将需要理解停车标志，即使它们是无用的。所以当你改变你的驾驶领域时，你就会为此做好准备。所以在DeepMind的方法中，你不仅重新生成了像Minecraft屏幕那样的东西，Minecraft屏幕然后会像，那是回到斑点里的东西吗？
Or is that just like a loss for the model to look at and say, hey, I also need to make sure this is somewhat stable? The Minecraft screen does not go back into the blob. Yeah. So you encode the original screen from like the very first screen. shot of the game and then you never encode anything else. And so the screen output is something that's just for humans or it's still part of the loss? Like you're still rewarding better preservation of future screens. Yeah, the screen output is part of the loss. So the way you train the model is
还是那只是模型的一个损失，让它看一眼并说，嘿，我也需要确保这在某种程度上是稳定的？Minecraft屏幕不会回到斑点里。是的。所以你从像游戏的第一个截图开始编码原始屏幕，然后你再也不会编码任何其他东西。所以屏幕输出是仅仅给人类看的东西，还是它仍然是损失的一部分？就像你仍然在奖励对未来屏幕更好的保存。是的，屏幕输出是损失的一部分。所以你训练模型的方式是
you have a video where you have the current screen and you have the next screen and you know, the action that was taken. So you generate the current screen, make sure it matches what came in. You take the action, generate the next screen, and make sure that matches the next screen that you have kind of in your... So it's still free to take its actions and it's just living in the latent space, but the latent space needs to continue to be grounded to what the real screen would have been. Yeah, actually, I kind of misspoke earlier. In the Dreamer case, you actually do need to have the clouds in your latent state because you need to regenerate them. Okay.
你有一个视频，你有当前屏幕，你有下一个屏幕，你知道，采取的行动。所以你生成当前屏幕，确保它与进入的内容匹配。你采取行动，生成下一个屏幕，并确保它与你拥有的下一个屏幕匹配，某种程度上在你的……所以它仍然可以自由采取行动，它只是生活在潜在空间中，但潜在空间需要继续扎根于真实屏幕本来的样子。是的，实际上，我之前有点说错了。在Dreamer的情况下，你实际上确实需要在你的潜在状态中有云，因为你需要重新生成它们。好的。
In the JEPA case, you don't because you're not regenerating them. But as you said, there's pros and cons to both. So in the, yeah, so in the dreamer case, like the leaves on the trees need to be present and sort of in the right place. But in JEPA, they would be just stripped down to something that would be the tree is a problem if you hit it, but as a concept, but you don't need to know about the little dangly bits on the end. Exactly. Yeah, the leaves would be just completely gone from the latent space in JEPA. Okay.
在JEPA的情况下，你不需要，因为你没有重新生成它们。但正如你所说，两者都有利弊。所以在，是的，所以在Dreamer的情况下，就像树上的叶子需要存在并且处于正确的位置。但在JEPA中，它们会被剥离到某种东西，即树是一个问题，如果你撞到它，作为一个概念，但你不需要知道末端的小悬挂部分。完全正确。是的，叶子在JEPA的潜在空间中会完全消失。好的。
This is like, it feels like one of those things that, to say world model or non-world model, like, it's like a very simple thing. Like, it's very straightforward. We can say these words, but the nuance is actually, like, pretty involved. Like, these people arguing about it feels like one of those things where, like, the average person, it's so far removed to understand the nuance of the argument or pick aside. Like, it's like super in the world. weeds. Yeah, I mean, you know, training on, you know, your own sort of like representation of the problem just carries with it all sorts of challenges, right? And that's unique to world models. So if you do like a model-based reinforcement learning, you don't have to worry about,
这就像，感觉像是那种，说世界模型或非世界模型，就像，它是一件非常简单的事情。就像，它非常直接。我们可以说这些话，但细微差别实际上是，像，相当复杂。就像，这些人争论它感觉像是那种，像，普通人，理解论点的细微差别或选边站太遥远了。就像，它就像超级在杂草里。是的，我的意思是，你知道，在你自己的某种问题表示上进行训练，本身就带有各种挑战，对吧？而且那是世界模型独有的。所以如果你做像基于模型的强化学习，你不需要担心，
oh, you know, my latent state thinks that I got a thousand points in chess, but I can only get one point. Like that's not something you have to worry about because all your rewards are explicit. And it sounds like from having looked a little bit at it that the argument is from the world model side is to use the other approaches is going to hit like a cat, like it'll run out. It can't do the sort of plan, long horizon planning that you might need to be like there's just lots of hangups. And then the reverse would be like you said, it's like, it's not as sophisticated today. Like the world models are further behind. But the argument is, yeah, they're further behind. They're harder to kind of like get going today. But eventually they should be more capable.
哦，你知道，我的潜在状态认为我在国际象棋中得到了一千分，但我只能得到一分。就像那不是你需要担心的事情，因为你所有的奖励都是明确的。而且听起来，从稍微看了一下它来看，论点是来自世界模型的一方，使用其他方法会遇到像一个猫，就像它会耗尽。它不能做那种你可能需要的计划，长远规划，就像有很多挂钩。然后反过来就像你说的，它就像，它今天没有那么复杂。就像世界模型落后得更远。但论点是，是的，它们落后得更远。它们今天更难启动。但最终它们应该更有能力。
Yeah. I mean, Rich Sutton actually, you know, he's famous for, well, a lot of things, but one of them is the bitter lesson. And he recently made a post where he tried to summarize the bitter lesson in 30 words or less. And I don't remember exactly a summary. I won't quote it, but the gist of it is, you know, if you, the more you remove the human out of the loop, the better it is. And that tends to just dominate everything else. So, and so in this case, you know, having a human craft a simulator, or having a human create a bunch of rules so that you don't need a simulator, like, oh, you're driving too far to the edge or something like that. You know, get, Getting those humans out of the loop is ultimately so much better in the long run than anything else.
是的。我的意思是，Rich Sutton实际上，你知道，他很有名，嗯，很多事情，但其中之一是“苦涩的教训”（bitter lesson）。他最近发了一篇文章，试图用30个字或更少的字总结苦涩的教训。我不记得确切的总结。我不会引用它，但它的要点是，你知道，如果你，你越把人类从循环中移除，它就越好。而且这往往会主导其他一切。所以，所以在这种情况下，你知道，让人类制作一个模拟器，或者让人类创造一堆规则，这样你就不需要模拟器，比如，哦，你开得太靠边了之类的。你知道，让那些人类离开循环，从长远来看最终比任何其他东西都要好得多。
And so, yeah, model-based RL has so many challenges. World models have even more challenges, but they will eventually win just because compute is so cheap and because, you know, humans have a hard time interacting with models at such a low level. Yeah, I mean, it certainly seems, I'm curious how, like, investor, I just off topic, sorry, or I'll off. I was like, people investing in this space that, I guess, people are just making bets or diversifying because it doesn't feel like if you're going to put financial backing, like example, to the world model from Yon Lekun getting, I think it was like a billion dollar investment or whatever.
所以，是的，基于模型的RL有很多挑战。世界模型有更多的挑战，但它们最终会赢，仅仅因为计算太便宜了，而且因为，你知道，人类很难在如此低的水平上与模型交互。是的，我的意思是，它看起来确实，我很好奇，像，投资者，我只是跑题了，抱歉，或者我跑题了。我当时想，人们投资这个领域，我猜，人们只是在下注或多元化，因为感觉不像如果你要投入财务支持，比如例子，给Yann LeCun的世界模型，我想那是像十亿美元的投资之类的。
You don't, you don't actually know. But the same was true, I guess, like Open AI and its original founding. Like, there was no evidence that where we are today with LLMs was attainable. So it's just very interesting to see. the investment sort of, I don't know to say, like, so far past the horizon. Like, it's not clear how to get from here to there. There's also just enormous survivor bias. Like, there's tons of open AIs that fell over, right? True. I think that, uh, um, I think that, you know, in the Al-Lacun's case, you know, he probably knows enough billionaires, right, that he only needs to get
你不知道，你实际上不知道。但同样的情况也是真的，我猜，像OpenAI及其最初的创立。就像，没有证据表明我们今天用LLM所处的位置是可以达到的。所以看到投资，某种程度上，我不知道怎么说，就像，远超地平线，非常有趣。就像，不清楚如何从这里到那里。还有巨大的幸存者偏差。就像，有成吨的OpenAI倒下了，对吧？真的。我认为，呃，嗯，我认为，你知道，在Yann LeCun的情况下，你知道，他可能认识足够的亿万富翁，对吧，他只需要得到
20 of them to each give five million or whatever it is. Yeah. Yeah. Uh, 50 million. Yeah. Um, So that's kind of what's going on there. In general, you know, starting a world model companies, probably not a good financial investment for anybody. But, you know, at some point it's really not about, for Jan, probably not about the money. It's about wanting to do this thing. And he's got the determination.
20个人，每个人给五百万或无论那是什么。是的。是的。5000万。是的。嗯，所以这就是那里发生的事情。总的来说，你知道，创办世界模型公司，对任何人来说可能都不是一个好的财务投资。但是，你知道，在某种程度上，这真的不是关于，对Yann来说，可能不是关于钱。这是关于想要做这件事。而且他有决心。
Yeah, I think it's also interesting for these companies. Do they tackle the, I know there's been a couple startups to say, we're not going to do any consumer products. We're just going straight to AGI. Like we, it's like a distraction. So I guess that's always a debate as well for someone like Yon Nakuna or whatever. Like, do you go for the thing that's far out that is like the ultimate prize? Or do you try to take incremental steps to prove the ideas or working and, you know, gain income?
是的，我认为这对这些公司来说也很有趣。他们是否解决，我知道已经有几个初创公司说，我们不会做任何消费产品。我们只是直接去AGI。就像我们，这就像一个干扰。所以我猜这也是某人像Yann LeCun或什么的争论。就像，你是去追求那个遥远的、作为终极奖品的东西吗？还是你试图采取渐进的步骤来证明想法是有效的，并且，你知道，获得收入？
Yeah, I mean, there's a ton of these companies that go nowhere, like safe superintelligence from Ilya, the guy who started Open AI. there's just so many of these companies where they just don't really go anywhere. So, but you know, everyone talks about the few that really succeed because that's just human nature. But I do think world models are a huge deal. I think that for two reasons. One, you can't have counterfactuals. You know, you can't just figure out, oh, I'm going to not drive over the bridge, drive off the cliff, through some trickery and engineering.
是的，我的意思是，有成吨的这些公司无处可去，比如Ilya的Safe Superintelligence，那个创办OpenAI的人。有太多的这些公司，它们真的无处可去。所以，但是你知道，每个人都谈论那些真正成功的少数，因为那是人性。但我确实认为世界模型是一件大事。我认为有两个原因。第一，你不能有反事实（counterfactuals）。你知道，你不能只是弄清楚，哦，我不会开车过桥，开车冲下悬崖，通过一些诡计和工程。
No, you actually have to drive off the cliff, which means you have to do it in sim. And then two is the sim to real problem is a non-starter. You know, it's just a mess, and trying to deal with that is just a nightmare. And you don't have to. Like, people, we don't need to use, like, some expensive simulator when Dreamer can just dream all of Minecraft.
不，你实际上必须开车冲下悬崖，这意味着你必须在模拟中做。然后第二是“从模拟到现实”的问题是一个无法开始的问题。你知道，它只是一团糟，试图处理那个简直是一场噩梦。而且你不需要。就像，人们，我们不需要使用，像，某种昂贵的模拟器，当Dreamer可以只是梦想整个Minecraft时。
Like, what's the point, right? So yeah, world models, definitely the future. But as far as a financial instrument, maybe not the best one. Is this where you give your disclosure about an investment, Jason? Yeah, full disclosure, I would never invest in. Oh, his company has less than 100 people. I think it's a terrible idea. Yeah, I think the survivorship bias is real because it's balanced, I guess, with FOMO, right?
就像，有什么意义呢，对吧？所以是的，世界模型绝对是未来。但作为一种金融工具，它可能不是最好的。Jason，这是你要进行投资披露的时候了吗？是的，完全披露，我永远不会投资。哦，他的公司不到100人。我觉得这是个糟糕的主意。是的，我认为幸存者偏差是真实存在的，因为它大概是被错失恐惧症（FOMO）所平衡了，对吧？
Like people have this like, oh, I can get in now. Now is the only time to get in and make a million X. you know and yeah it's but you know like yeah you're so much better off um betting on things that have already won and getting like a four X versus like wasting your money on a you know epsilon percent chance so this has been my strategy as well but i i i can look at other people who didn't take this strategy and are better off so yeah yeah yeah but so many other people have lost their hat, you know. That's the thing, right?
就像人们会有这种想法，哦，我现在可以入场了。现在是入场并获得百万倍收益的唯一时机，你知道的，是的，但你知道，其实你最好还是押注那些已经成功的项目，获得四倍收益，而不是把钱浪费在那种只有极小概率成功的项目上。这也是我一直以来的策略，但我确实看到其他人没有采取这种策略却过得更好，所以，是的，是的，但也有很多人赔得血本无归，你知道的。这就是问题所在，对吧？
You only think about the people ahead of you, but yeah, yeah, it's a human rights. I was actually thinking about this the other day. I know we're short on time, but I was thinking about all the startups that have reached out to me, probably to you too, over the past, you know, 15 years and how almost all of them have failed catastrophically. Or, you know, if not, okay, that's a bad terminology, not failed catastrophic, but almost all of them have underperformed just going to a big company. Like literally, I can't even think of one that outperformed just staying at, you know, a big company that's successful. So, um, so, uh, yeah,
你只会想到那些走在你前面的人，但确实，这是一种人权。我前几天还在想这件事。我知道我们时间不多了，但我一直在想过去15年来联系过我的所有初创公司，可能也联系过你，它们几乎全都惨败了。或者，你知道，如果不是这样，好吧，这个词用得不好，不是惨败，但它们几乎全都表现平平，还不如去一家大公司。真的，我甚至想不出一家表现优于留在一家成功大公司的初创公司。所以，嗯，所以，是的，
I mean, you know, maybe we could have joined one of these, uh, things, companies that are IPOing this year. But, but, but again, like, that's, that's hindsight. There's also like hundreds of other companies that didn't go anywhere. So, Words of wisdom from Jason. Yeah, totally. Run so you don't die and invest in already sure things. All right, got it. Run so you don't die and winners keep winning.
我的意思是，你知道，也许我们本可以加入这些今年进行首次公开募股（IPO）的公司之一。但是，但是，但是再说一次，那是事后诸葛亮。还有成百上千家公司根本没折腾出什么名堂。Jason的至理名言。是的，完全正确。跑吧，这样你就不会死，投资那些已经确定的事情。好了，明白了。跑吧，这样你就不会死，赢家会一直赢下去。
You know, in the movies, it's like the underdog, you know, Rudy. Remember Rudy, the football movie? Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah, the 4'10, you know, linebacker, like, just through his heart and determination, like, wins Notre Dame. I don't know. I've never seen the movie, but, but like, in reality, the Brock Lesnar, who's like 6'6 and all muscle,
你知道，在电影里，就像那个失败者，你知道，《鲁迪》吗？记得《鲁迪》那部橄榄球电影吗？是的，是的，是的，是的。那个4英尺10英寸的后卫，凭借他的勇气和决心，赢得了圣母大学的比赛。我不知道。我没看过那部电影，但就像在现实中，像布洛克·莱斯纳那样身高6英尺6英寸、浑身肌肉的人，
he just wins and just crushes everybody. Like that's how the real world works. I hate to break it to you out there. But like winners generally just keep winning. Wow, dude. We get spun up. It's late in the episode. I feel like I'm ever going to get a rant here.
他就是赢，就是碾压所有人。现实世界就是这样运作的。我很抱歉打破你们的幻想。但赢家通常就是会一直赢下去。哇，伙计。我们有点激动了。这期节目快结束了。我觉得我在这里发表了一通长篇大论。
Do you have an X account for where we can hear more? Oh, man. All right. Well, thank you for, yeah, I feel like that was, that was great. I enjoyed hearing the explanation and super pertinent to current events. Totally, yeah. If you're out there, you're working on world models or have any questions. Hit us up on Discord or shoot us an email and you can get links to all of that from our website,
你有X账号让我们了解更多吗？哦，天哪。好吧。嗯，谢谢你，是的，我觉得这太棒了。我很喜欢听这个解释，而且与当前事件非常相关。完全正确，是的。如果你在外面，正在研究世界模型或者有任何问题。在Discord上联系我们，或者给我们发电子邮件，你可以从我们的网站上获得所有这些链接，
programming threadon.com. Or one last shout out. I guess if you're working at one of them, maybe you have a private jet and can fly us out and we'll interview you. That's true. Yeah, we'll do interviews in person. We just need a private jet. I've never been on one. It would be cool. It's not cheap. No. No. All right. Thanks, everybody. All right. Catch you all later.
programmingthrowdown.com。或者最后再喊一声。我想如果你在其中一家公司工作，也许你有私人飞机可以接我们过去，我们会采访你。那是真的。是的，我们会进行面对面采访。我们只需要一架私人飞机。我从来没坐过。那会很酷。那可不便宜。不。不。好了，谢谢大家。好了，回头见。
Music by Eric Barn Dollar. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons attribution, share a like, 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work to remix adapt the work but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and share a like and kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
音乐由Eric Barn Dollar创作。Programming Throwdown在知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0许可协议下发布。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输该作品，也可以重新混合和改编该作品，但你必须注明我和Patrick的署名，并以相同方式共享。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。